it's not a coincidence that the first
atomic bomb a detonation on Earth by
human beings was done not far from where
Roswell is in New Mexico or the first
this crash that occurred 1947 with alien
bodies and alien spacecraft and so forth
many of these phenomena do occur around
military installations to this very
these people should aren't they worried
about like encountering these phenomena
they're really seen every day as Ryan
told me they're seen every day and
people report cubes and spheres or
spheres and Cub there's a psychological
component that's fundamentally not
scientific it doesn't mean that don't
[Music]
wrong
Brian keing you made it to New Jersey
thank you for coming out here sir first
time here in a while it's good to be
back uh good to be back on the East
Coast as a New Yorker it's uh always a
little bit of a danger going to New
Jersey but for you I brave it my friend
well it's a lot easier getting you to
New Jersey than Florida my boy Danny
Jones has been trying for 18 months so
to the punch I'm going to see him I'm
seeing him right after I see our mutual
friend Jordan Peterson and Peterson
Academy coming up soon oh what are you
doing up there so uh Jordan starting
this University to kind of combat both
the excessive high prices the kind of uh
insane campus politics and so forth so
he's asked a couple of Faculty members
to join um and to you know present
courses on their subject matter
expertise has nothing to do with
politics or ideology whatsoever it's
completely neutral I'll be teaching
about cosmology and you know there's not
too much we have our big bangs in
cosmology but we're not going to talking
about woke versus you know you know
antifa and no that's not what my goal is
so it's it's going to be an interesting
experience so he has a whole studio
there he built with his it's really his
daughter Michaela it's in Miami it's in
Miami yeah yeah so I'll be there and
then I'm gonna catch a ride across the
state to the to the pan I've never been
to Tampa I'm GNA see our mutual buddy
Danny Boy I can't wait Tampa's fun
Tampa's a good town is it don't don't
have too much fun there anyway you
didn't hear that from me but yeah I I
connect with you back in May and now
since we put this on the calendar you
blew the up cuz you went on Joe Rogan
that's right the goat Scoops me once
again never well all you need here is is
an archery range and a couple of Life
life-size werewolves and a picture of
CLA Schwab over the toilet you got uh
Austin scoop my buddy you're on your way
your trajectory look at Joe he's
saturating you know you're still Rising
he's got a CLA Schwab picture above the
toilet yeah so you're holding your uh
your business and you're doing your
business and you're looking into the
cold Bey eyes of a I don't think I could
piss I don't think anything would happen
i' be a I like is it the old age is it
my prostate or what's going on oh no
it's clous it's these cold dead eyes of
the world economic Forum looking at me
yeah that's a whole if we go down that
rabbit hole we'll be there all day but
we got things to talk about but I had
connected with you because I had meuk
Kaku in for the podcast at I recorded
with him at the end of April and so when
that came out
I did a little mini documentary that's
still on my channel now just covering
kind of like the 8 and 1 half minute
response within the podcast that meu
gave to your friend Eric Weinstein's
criticism that he had had for meu a few
months before when he was on Joe Rogan
and here's the context there for those
of you who aren't familiar if you can't
stand the heat get out of the kitchen
and to be in the heat means yeah to be
criticized well you and I were looking
at a video right before we went on
camera I wanted to show you in case you
didn't have the context but we were
watching a video of Eric Weinstein on
Joe Rogan recently where he was I guess
like having a moment with string theory
and going off about it David Gross and
Ed Wht should be in front of the
community explaining why did you take
all the smartest people all the
resources all the
attention Meo Kaku get Meo Kaku in here
with
me Meo Kaku is out of control
TR Sean Carol is covering up for this as
well in what way they are too kind Brian
Green like I had this interchange with
Brian Green where I said you
know
we're not being honest about the failure
of string theory Brian's like oh well
maybe we were a little bit exuberant and
I I blurred out Institute for arts and
ideas I blurred
out that's like saying M ey
my Mei was irrational exuberance no you
put a lot of people's careers in the in
the
shredder and for people that aren't
familiar with that we'll I'll let you
explain the details but we had gone back
and forth and I felt like first of all
it it would be really cool to see Eric
and Meo in a room and I hope if that
happens it's you who does it that would
be really really cool but the the core
of that argument was over of course
String Theory which Eric has presented
his own Theory geometric unity and
string theory is obviously heavily
debated within the Science World because
it hasn't been proven but I I guess
where we stand almost 50 years since
string theory was was invented where
where where are you on that issue do you
think it's it's something where we need
to move past it now because it hasn't
been proven and can't be tested or do
you think it's it's a matter of it just
has too much too much of like a little
bit of an iron wall around it and we
should be looking at other opportunities
as well yeah yeah he asked a lot of good
good questions there so I'll start with
um I'll start with the original kind of
um statement about miio and Eric uh
first of all you have you have to
realize it's kind of surprising that in
this very relatively Arcane abstruse
abstract form of mathematical physics
that there are battles every much as
intense as the East Coast West Coast Rap
Battles of the 1990s that you probably
don't remember but I do know about those
Biggie and Tupac and uh there you go
that's right uh not far from here and
then where I'm from on the the West
Coast um and so literally we have East
Coasters Ed Whitten mitaku and uh then
we have the West Coast gang and out
there with Eric and and others taking an
alternative approach so it's surprising
that there's so much heat and passion
that generated behind it and partially I
think the reason is is that mathematics
has always held a special status in the
culture mathematics is part of culture
it's not divorc from it it's not some
thing you use as a tool to do something
else um in and of itself mathematics has
a power to Captivate the mind and I
think mathematicians and so forth are
some of the most respected
people in in the world for their
Brilliance for their intellect and so
it's very different subject from almost
any other subject in that things in math
are not necessarily real in fact I
interviewed a a young
um she has a PHD in math but she's not a
professor named Eugenia Chang and she
has a book called is math real basically
does math exist so I always say can you
give me a triangle no but you can think
about a triangle can you give me a
complex number no but we can think about
a complex number can you even give me
Infinity no but you can think about
Infinity in ways that computers can't
even do it so there are these things
that are purely products of the human
mind and I think the Pinnacle of the
human mind is mathematics and and it is
the basis of all the physics and so
forth that I do now I'm an
experimentalist I build instrumentation
my goal is to see not if these people
are right but to prove them wrong my job
is to be the Exterminator of their
theories there's no such thing as a
proof in physics hey guys for the month
of October 72% just under is about
71.6% of our viewers were not subscribed
if you could take two seconds less than
two seconds really like one second and
smash that subscribe Button as well as
that notifications Bell we're going to
have a better number there we'll be able
to get into the algorithm more and
continue to get great guests and even
better guests as we move forward we got
some awesome people coming up throughout
the rest of December and January
including a return from a fan favorite
Matt Cox as well as Joe Tedy and Matt
lroy and a lot of new people as well who
you're going to love so hit that
subscribe button smash that
notifications Bell as well and enjoy the
rest of the show thank you so you you
mentioned like we because we we don't
have proof or we can't be proven nothing
in physics can be Pro we can't prove
there was a big bang I can't prove
there's not a purple unicorn on UR I
mean there's no way to falsify every
statement that you could make about
physics it doesn't make it
scientifically accurate but mathematics
you can so in other words you can
determine what is property of
mathematical perview in other what is
kosher what is acceptable what is part
of the project in mathematics because it
can be proven or falsified we may not be
able to do it it took famously 300 years
between firmat you know coming up with
this Last Theorem where he put it in the
margins of of a little paperback that he
was reading at the time before it was
proven by Andrew while is not far from
here in uh in in in Princeton New Jersey
and so you think about things that can
be proven it gives physicist a little
bit of Envy because we can't prove
anything in physics I was going to say
you you you don't really have it it
seems to me like even when you look at
some of the core tenants like people
will talk about gravity well that'll
probably never be disproven do we know
that though you know what I mean because
think about how short human history's
even been to this point and how much is
out there that we have no clue about
like gravity for all intensive purposes
could be in in an entirely different
like I'm gonna make up a term here but
like dimensional wavelength than we
understand it no yeah I'm not we we
don't talk about dimensional wavelengths
but we will talk about uh kind of an
analogy actually you put every theory
that every physicist has ever had onto a
pingpong ball and you put it into a big
55 gallon oil drum okay and you just
pulled them out 99 of out of every
hundred of those pingpong balls would
have a theory that was proven to be
wrong visional Incorrect and I think now
it's no different maybe it's even worse
because it's never been easier to phys
theory is like software you know it's
it's easy to generate a lot of software
and say I'm going to go back it's called
technical debt you I'm going to go back
and fix up these lines in the Cod I'm
going to document famously I don't know
if you ever wrote computer code I'm
terrible at this I'd love to write it
super fun but you're supposed to
document what you're doing so that
somebody else can come and do you know
can do uh some some postmortem analysis
on why you have this bug that led to you
know10 billion doar of you know of alam
coin to drop to zero or whatever right
so you should document then um I never
do it so that's technical debt I'm going
to go back and do it so it's easy to
produce it and forget to do the
documentation to do the technical debt
that you're supposed to do um but
experiments not easy to make an
experiment we're you know I'm part of
the leadership of a hundred million doll
project in Chile called the Simon
Observatory that's taken almost eight
years to come to fruition to get its
first Photon from the universe and it's
not even a photon from The Big Bang it's
a it's a photon from from uh you know
the planet Mars it's nothing that you
would write home about but that's how
long it's taken 380 people 7 years
working on so you never do some like
it's not easy to produce experiments
it's very hard that's why every
experiment in my opinion should be
decisive it should have a clear-cut goal
what it's going to do because we never
know we we serve at the I mean if we
were living in Ukraine right now you
know we living in in um in Israel or
Gaza like we wouldn't be doing physic I
wouldn't be doing my colleagues wouldn't
be doing physics right now we'd be a
scared for our lives trying to figure
out how to survive um the other thing
we'd be doing is you know probably
working on a military you know project
somewhere a physicist would be working
on some military camp and this is true
throughout history physicists have
always worked hand inand or astronomers
with the military uh and so what's been
really interesting to me is to see that
we only get to do this we serve at the
pleasure of peaceful circumstances we do
some of the most esoteric as I said
Arcane abstruse things that you can do
that actually serve no purpose like what
I'm doing 100 million doll you could put
that to cancer research you could put
that to you know whatever you're saying
and maybe it would be doing more good
maybe it wouldn't or food just buying
food I guarantee or mosquito Nets it
would definitely do more good ultimately
um but uh but sometimes I think that's
what we should be doing because things
that have no quote unquote purpose are
what make human beings human and
distinguish and different I mean animals
provide for their their kids and there's
even some notion of altruism in the
animal kingdom as Stephen Pinker and
other people will tell you right yeah so
the question is what makes us uniquely
human it's doing things that are useless
useless to benefit it's not going to
make a faster although phones did come
at cell phones did come out of the
research in radio astronomy that I'm not
that I did but the the Legacy that I'm
you know air to created the technology
right down the road here in New Jersey
in central New Jersey in Homedale in a
uh at Bell Labs the technology that
you're carrying in your pocket right and
that was concomitant with the discovery
of the origin of the universe via the
cosmic microwave background radiation
that I study so getting back to your
first question um these guys are doing
stuff that's very important but it may
not be very significant in other words
we may never be able to have evidence
for it now just because we don't have
evidence I don't have evidence for a
supernova what what blew up and created
this little piece of meteorite that I
gave you as as gratitude for hosting me
and I give it all out to my visitors on
my website you go to Brian king.com I I
give those away four billion years old
four billion years old and I'll send you
the information about it uh when you
join my my email list you get the assay
the chemical composition you get the uh
origin and you get also a guide on how
to see meteor showers because I think
that's super cool and you can see them
here even in the middle of Manhattan yep
you can see you can see meteor showers
now it's not it's going to be as good as
if you come to the dark desert of
California where I live yeah so it's
going to be a lot better when you come
and do my podcast I only do we'll do it
in person with you you made me come up
to New Jersey I'm gonna make you come to
I'll be I will be there uh so anyway so
we we can look for things that we can't
uh we can't we can see the indirect
evidence for things that we can't
witness that Supernova produced that
chunk of meteorite that chunk is the
byproduct of a fusion reaction that
terminated when a star can no longer
support its girth its mass and it
succumb the pressure that was felt
succumb to a nuclear fusion event that
then catastrophically exploded that star
out into the universe how do we date
something like that um well you go to
Tinder and no you that's the only dating
I used to be no so uh so these are dated
by their composition their their isotope
ratios and also the fact that uh they
they can be determined to have you know
this the the the metall the same
metallic origin We compare with a model
for how these stars form and then they
end their life so there was a star in
our neighborhood of the Milky Way galaxy
that predated our Milky Way galaxy and
when it got to the end of its life when
it started to fuse heavier and heavier
elements together that no longer gave
off enough energy to bloat out the
anymore to keep the pressure needed to
to counteract the gravitational force of
the of the outer layers of this
onionlike star um the last thing it
produces is called iron it's iron and
heavy elements and that's why this thing
is so dense and you can verify it's so
dense it's also magnetic you can you
know stick it to a magnet very this is
magnetic yeah it's highly magnetic yeah
if you had one here if you have a
magnetic bobblehead maybe that I don't
yeah we got to get you on I got to test
that so um and the exact composition of
that meteorite is found in our Earth as
as well and as well as in the Rocky core
of our planet and and the other inner
rocky planets so we can date that they
came from the same Supernova so the
death of another star provided the
impetus the material the raw ingredients
that made our planet and also is then
found in the crust of our planet so
there's iron inside of the crust of the
earth that came from that same Supernova
that produced that iron chunk right here
and some of that iron made itself into
wheat and so forth that your mother ate
when she was pregnant with you and
eventually your body synthesized into to
make hemoglobin so the hemoglobin
molecule that fixes air that basically
allows you to live and breathe as a you
know as a breathing individual that uh
that iron came from the same meteor that
came from or came from the same event
that produ that now we didn't witness
any of that so why am I saying all this
because we also can't witness like
what's happening in a 10 to Theus 30th
meters in a vibrating 10-dimensional
super string right that's not something
we can have access to but we can defer
from the downstream effects what these
models would predict for things that we
haven't seen so if I see that thing
there and I say that same model predicts
that there should be an isotope ratio if
if the iron if what I said was not a lie
okay that the iron in your blood came
from the same Supernova explosion that
produced that meteorite then I've just
made a testable prediction you can test
the isotope ratio in your blood and it
won't be pure iron 56 or whatever it is
it'll have some isotope ratio and it'll
be the same as that and that came from
space that was witness the was witness
it's it came from Argentina you'll learn
all about it when you click on the the
link in my uh in my newsletter and that
has a chemical assay and it's very very
similar to the chemical composition in
your body so that's a model prediction
now String Theory the question is can it
predict anything you're bringing you're
doing my job for me I love it you're
great well I've learned a lot from you
you've actually helped me grow the into
the impossible podcast you know 100,000
subscribers in L than a year your
channel is still by by the way I will
have all your links in our description
channel in my opinion is still massively
underrated I mean the people you're
getting on there I mean you're so
connected in the field but it's it's
incredible yeah it's been you know they
say like when you get to the top of the
mountain where you're closer to than I
am or you know someone like Joe or
something like Joe Rogan who's who's a
wonderful I call him you know the the
biggest mench in the business he's
influenced so many of us right and uh he
gives us kind of a Target to Aspire to
yeah and when I was on the podcast with
him I asked him like what are your goal
cuz I was like you're always asking
everybody else like what are your goals
in the podcast like what do you want to
do and where is your kind of promised
land for where you want to go and he was
just like I have this life that's like a
Life by design that allows me to not
necessarily have freedom to do anything
although he does I mean he owns a comedy
story he probably flies private he does
whatever but he has freedom from he
doesn't have a boss I mean he advertises
stuff that he makes like it's not like
oh well like U I don't know who your
advertisers I saw some some powders out
there I'm not I don't know if I should
mention them or not don't mention them
yet I W mention them okay fine uh but
there's some delicious stuff out there
um and uh you know but like when I have
an Advertiser I have to do it and then
the sponsor comes back oh you misplaced
the you know kind of product placement
or my favorite is you were supposed to
log in to this link that you know is
where you're or people are going to
access I'm like the content's still
there like why do I have to log in and
they like well someone might see that
it's like Brian keing or or not Brian
keing it's just like new user oh my God
so I'm like thanks now I have a boss
this is what Ari has to do for you you
should tell him to take care I know I
love hopefully we'll see him um so but
the bottom line is when you have
something that makes predictions more
powerful a scientific theory is the more
predictions it can make and the more
retrodictions it can explain in other
words it can explain things that used to
happen you ask me about gravity so will
we ever know that gravity has been o
overturned or we were wrong I suspect no
and the reason is because we know it's
already wrong it's wrong in in a certain
sense when we say that something is a
scientific fact let's say I say do you
believe the Earth is round yes okay well
you're totally wrong you now if I say to
you is the earth flat you'll say no you
also be you'll you'll be right if you
say no right but we have proven that
though because it's here we we okay so
the earth now I'm going to go into
Professor mode okay this is my wife
loves this uh so the Earth is not a
perfect sphere right it has some
spherical property it's actually pretty
oblate it has it has properties like a
pair but it's not flat it's not flat so
if you said it's flat you're wrong if
you say it's a sphere you're wrong but
as Isaac azimov said you're less wrong
if you say it's a sphere than if it's a
flat if you said it was perfectly flat
now what is that imply that means that
there would be some perfect there is
some perfect description and even if I
said it's pear-shaped I'm also wrong but
it's getting closer and closer to the
scientific truth science is not about
saying provable facts again we can't
prove that fat that the Earth is a
prolate spheroid with these spherical
harmonic contributions at distortions at
this you know 0 one% level the way that
I can prove 2 plus 2 equal 4 even though
that'll take 400 pages of abstract
mathematics to prove that simple
sounding statement you can't say oh you
have one finger you no no no that's not
what we're talking about the actual
mathematics behind proving 2 plus 2
equal 4 is significantly Advanced it's
not it's not basic mathematics like I
teached you to a you know 5-year-old but
there is no such thing as proving
physically that the Earth is a sphere or
a pair or whatever shape you want a
donut there is no way to prove that
there scientifically all we can do is
say something is wrong but what you
should do is say things that are
accurate as much as you can with
Precision so let me talk about the
difference between accuracy and
precision if I say you weigh less than a
th000 pounds I mean you've been going to
the gym you look pretty pretty pretty
pretty diesel buddy but um but you
definitely do that's accurate is it
precise doesn't tell you anything
absolutely correct it is not precise so
you want to have accuracy and precision
so I want to say the Earth is not a
sphere then I have to add some terms to
it that makes it more precise but it's
still not perfectly accurate so you want
to try to convert now my question and I
think what Eric you know complains about
people like Mitch okaku is that he'll
say something akin to you weigh less
than a th000 pound and he'll say isn't
this great we now have a scientifically
testable you know fact that okay so I
actually had literally one of the
fathers of modern String Theory his name
is Kon vafa he's a brilliant man
wonderful mench of a guy up at up at
Harvard and he was on my podcast and he
said no Brian it's not true that string
theory doesn't make any predictions he
basically said no string theory predicts
the mass the electron and I was like I
didn't know that uh that's kind of news
to me what is it what's the pred first
of all it's not a prediction it's a
retrod we already have the measurement
so now he's saying where does it come
from purely mathematically within the
confines of of the limitations of string
theory he said yes we have limits on it
I said obviously you're not going to say
it's exactly you know 10 to the minus 28
pump up with 65 decimal places behind
the 28 no no but he said it's greater
than effectively it would be like saying
you're weigh between 1 kilogram you and
10 to the 30th k
except it's put a negative sign yeah but
look what could what could those numbers
be Julian what could possibly be pick a
number what what what is the range of
those exponents it could be anything
from negative Infinity to positive
Infinity yeah numbers we can't concept
at all exactly but not only that we
can't concept so actually it's a very
accurate thing within the broad range of
all it could be from negative Infinity
to positive Infinity right so it's
actually very accurate right just like
me saying like you between um zero
pounds and infinity pounds okay so a
very I put a th000 kilograms rather uh
that's very acccurate compared to what
that could be the SP so that's why I
think people like Eric and people like
me to be hon I won't speak for Eric but
but for me get frustrated because um
when we talk when we hear other
theorists talk about this I get very
upset uh because I think that their job
is is very envious they get to literally
think they don't they don't necessarily
have to travel to Chile and deal with um
you know dumping Concrete in the wrong
place and getting electri you think it
was hard to set up this beautiful Studio
imagine doing that 17,000 ft wearing a
hard hat oxygen mask steel toed boots
wearing a life saving vest in case you
fall over and die getting checked for
all sorts of high altitude sickness and
diseases having to pass a physical exam
you know versus sitting in your office
yeah sitting in your office and you know
living the life of the mind now when you
ask those people when I ask sabinaa
Hassen Felder or ask um Steven wol from
and I say well what do you think about
Eric's Theory or what do you think about
uh um you know Steven's Theory to to
Saina Hassen Phil and they'll say oh I
don't have time you don't have time like
what else are you working on I mean
she's got a thriving YouTube channel and
she's a she's you know that's great
that's her job now and she she is doing
research and and she's to be commended
for it but she's not a professor she's
not doing and even is neither is Steven
wlfr he's not a professor I mean he ears
a business and he's very good at what he
does but to say I don't have time all I
have time for is to look at my own uh
Theory and and kind of verify that would
be like me saying I'm going to ignore
these other experiments that actually
saying Brian keing you saw dust you
claimed to see the origin of the
universe you saw dust you're a fraud
you're a charlatan you're a g if I just
did that and I didn't listen to the
critics that would be pathetic and and
yet I do feel like there's an
unwillingness for these theorists to
spend refering to your bicep that's the
bicep exp okay yeah but do you think
part of that and by the way I don't
agree with this but think part of that
is a little bit of that Ivory Tower of
well the guy you're talking about with
Eric Weinstein is is a he's a
mathematician he's not even a physicist
so they don't want to quote unquote
waste their time with it you think no ER
Eric's a a dominant you know force in
the intellectual you know intellectual
sphere no I don't think that's that's
true at all he do he will I'll get
frustrated with him because he'll often
say oh I'm just a mathematician but in
reality I mean he's claiming to impinge
upon the traditional Pathways of of
modern physics including that of you
know uh of maybe pre-discovery certain
foundational equations that have led to
you know the so-called string Revolution
and other things while he was a graduate
student and there's documentation about
this from his thesis no he he traffics
in in physics it's just highly
mathematical physics which is fine Ma
mathematicians have been or physicists
have been contributing to mathematics
since you know long before you know
Alexander of Samos and you know there
there's Aristotle there there are you
know obviously Isaac Newton you know C
discovered calculus or invented calculus
depending on how you think about it
significant overlap for sure yeah huge
part of it but if if you had to explain
to like the Layman out there to get at
the core of what we've been coming
around to with like the the Kaku camp
and like the Weinstein camp
like what is string theory in your
estimation and what is it that Eric is
proposing with geometric Unity I think
there's a there's a misg gued um
Fascination Focus Obsession in some
sense with um with string theory string
theory has gotten a tremendous amount of
attention and this is sociological
perhaps uh and and possibly because of
the authority bias that's that's always
present when you have a field as um
there's no there's no telling how much
respect people have for mathematics and
physics and I'm talking about
intellectuals there was a famous
Japanese po who won the Nobel Prize in
literature and he told his mother and
his mother said well that's great but I
thought I always thought you'd be a
physicist you know she was disappointed
like he's one of you know a hundred
people still alive or even fewer right
so you think about like what is the
Pinnacle of human brain power it's
typically a math and I'm not a
mathematician I'm not toting my own horn
I'm an experimental physicist which is
several levels down in the Public's
estimation of it who do you know as a
physicist all just around the corner
Brian Green Jan 11
um as I said Steven Wolfram Steven
Hawking you know the names that people
know Lenny suskin all these people I've
had on i' on 14 Nobel Prize winners in
physics alone on my podcast plus several
others from other disciplines they're
almost all theoretical physicists which
is as close to math as you can get in
physics um what I feel is missing from
all these discussions from all these Ser
is a recognition that they are for some
reason uh putting the cart before the
horse or in my case I call this the the
the toe before the gut and it's it's a
hilarious pun trust me Julian um so
there's something in physics called
unification unification is the
recognition that seemingly disparate
phenomena like electricity you know
lightning bolts static cling and what
have you and magnetism the stuff of uh
of refrigerator magnets and levitating
trains that those are actually two sides
of the same coin called electromagnetism
and they're actually different
manifestations and this is a key Insight
in Einstein's special theory of
relativity it was understood by uh by
James Clerk Maxwell who laid the
foundations for modern mathematical
physics of of electrodynamics and many
other things that actually an observer
in motion so let's say you you see a
charge here there's just a static charge
it's just sitting there you and I see it
we're static and we see it as producing
an electric field that radiates away
from a positive charge or converges on a
negative charge as convention right U
and yet uh if you have somebody sliding
by on a train you know down the street
they will see that charge in motion how
do you reconcile those two things and by
the way a charge in motion produces
What's called the current currents are
the sources of magnetic fields so how
can you reconcile those two things with
the statement that motion is relative
there's no such thing as absolute
velocity you and I can't say that
someone in a car and you've had this
experience you're sitting on a train at
at you know Penn Station the train next
to you starts to move you're like oh
we're moving no you're not moving you're
stationary no one can tell when a obser
or a participant is in relative constant
motion they can't say that you're in
relative constant motion they can only
say according to me you're in motion
with some velocity and some direction
are you talking I I want to make sure
just for people who are following are
you talking about the difference in what
I can see if like you physically saw me
running versus me sitting on the train
and you only saw me sitting on the train
you didn't see the train itself moving
at constant velocity it almost doesn't
make a difference if you're carrying a
charge then somebody running at the same
speed as you would see that charge being
static and there for only producing a
static electric field however me sitting
on the ground lazily sipping my
delicious coffee I would see you moving
with a charge therefore you'd be
producing a current therefore I would
see that you're going to produce a
magnetic field not an electric field
there would be no electric field there'
be an electric magnetic field what
Maxwell realized is that uh is that
those are two sides of the same coin
electricity one one man's electric field
is another man's magnetic field okay so
what's so important about that is that
there was a unification actually one
thing called the electromagnetic field
when did he come up with that 1850s
1860s um he died very young like 40
years old he's been um and then even he
as brilliant as he was he thought that
these waves traveled through a medium
called The Ether that was rejected 50 or
60 years later but but essentially he
didn't understand he could have a wave
of light electromagnetism which he also
discovered how could you have a wave
traveling through a vacuum where there's
no medium there's no such we we're
talking now there's sound waves
emanating from pressure and density
perturbations that get picked up by
little diaphragm pressure and density
what variations or vibrations yeah yeah
per oh
pertubations what the [__] is that
that's some of the things you can't that
sound dirty but are not yeah okay I'm
going to go perate myself later on uh so
when you think about how um you know how
these things are two sides of the same
coin the same thing exists with nuclear
physics and particle physics and quantum
mechanics there are people that say
there are four forces of nature there's
electricity magnetism that's one force
now it used to be two Force now it's one
force there's something called the weak
nuclear force this is responsible for
radioactive decay so when a when a
neutron decays and shoots off an
electron a neutrino Anton neutrino and
and a proton those objects are are part
of what's called weak nuclear Decay okay
then there's a strong force of
electromagnetism uh sorry a strong force
of the nucleus which is responsible you
ever think like how does I don't think
most people think about this but helium
has two protons in its nucleus neutal
you never well we're going to see the
the Macy's day parade soon so when you
see the helium balloon think about the
fact that helium has two protons in its
nucleus okay what do you know about like
charges Julian not much assume
nothing like charges repel what do you
know about opposites Oh I thought you
said like charges not like like yeah
they repel oppos attract so how does
this protons how these two protons stick
together they're both positively
charge we would have to break that mold
well you have to have some other Force
that's stronger than the electrostatic
repulsion between two like charges and
that's called the strong force it indeed
exist then there's the fourth Force
which you're very familiar with because
you're you know you're jacked right
that's called gravity so you're working
against gravity you go to the gym you do
what the question is can we unify more
of those forces we already unified
electricity and magnetism into one force
so we basically reduced five forces to
four forces then they reduced another
force in the 60s and 70s one of my past
guests Sheldon glashow inspiration for
young Sheldon on The you know the Big
Bang Theory oh [__] really yeah um so
he's a Nobel laan up in Boston he and
his colleagues Steven Weinberg and Abdus
Salam they uh invented a way to unify
together the weak nuclear force with the
electric and magnetic force and that's
called Electro week Theory so now we've
reduced five forces down to two down to
three Electro weak and then gravity and
the strong nuclear force okay now the
question is can you unify the strong
nuclear force with the Electra weak
Force that's called Grand unified theory
if those were shown to be the
manifestation of one single Force then
you'd have two left guess what we'd want
to do next unify a strong plus Electro
weak with gravity that's called The
Theory of Everything that in some sense
is the unification that Eric attempts to
achieve and that string theory attempts
to achieve so they're trying to achieve
the ultimate unification but wait
there's a problem it would be like we
built the second and third floor of this
Penthouse apartment here but we never
built the basement or the first floor
other words we have not yet come to an
agreement or any testable theory for
what's called Grand unification
abbreviation gut so I always joke back
to my hilarious joke yeah the toe before
the gut putting the toe before the gut
and I do that on a scale because I can't
look down but but if you look at these
phenomena why is there an obsession with
this and I think it's because because of
what your B past guessed Mito said if
you could get this equation perhaps one
inch long I'm going to try to channel
perhaps one inch long it could take you
to the top you would then have known and
knowledge of the mind of God yes that's
why he calls it that but wait a second
how can you know the mind of God if you
don't know his like packs and his and
his Cranium cuz you don't have the gut
you don't have the gut miio so why are
you doing that why because what did he
say inspired him the most on this very
chair in this very type of Studio when
you he said Einstein he said when he
died he KN noted that Einstein had on
his desk a piece of paper and he was
working so hard and it was to come up
with this Theory of Everything it's not
really what he was doing he certainly
wasn't doing String Theory what he was
referring to it as yeah more than yeah I
mean it was his it was his holy grail
his promised land and Mio wanted to not
take over well we don't have a grand
unified theory if Mito had come up at as
an age whatever he was when Einstein
died I want to be a theortical physicist
and understand how to unify together the
strong nuclear force with the
electromagnetic force he would have won
probably multiple Nobel prizes and also
did what Einstein didn't do but because
of this Allure of being the next
Einstein and so forth people like him
and and others have built up people like
Ed Whitten into these superhuman
intellects that almost too much is
invested in for it to not be right
although there's no evidence for it that
was the guy
that Eric was in in that same sit down
with Joe Rogan when he talked about
mitcho Whitten was the guy who he was
like I am so intimidated by this man
he's so smart or whatever and but he
hasn't he's Voldemort he's he's another
guy who's smack in the middle of of
Defending String Theory well he's one of
the foremost you know progenitors of of
one of the closest and key insights of
string theory which is originally the
string theory had 26 dimension mention I
would say can we break it down for
people yeah so string theory is a
mathematical uh conception that attempts
to do uh a unification of quantum
mechanics which is the theory of the
atomic world in the realm of the
electrons and protons and crout no the
electrons and neutrons and so forth and
their con constituent particles
including things like quarks and then uh
and then combine them in a uh
unification schema to make them
compatible with gravity to have a part
particle of gravity effectively that
acts on the space this very esoteric
mathematical space and for technical
reasons you can't do it in the Ordinary
World of three-dimensional space that
you and I love and enjoy combined with
time so time plus space is called space
time it is a network of points
mathematically arbitrarily speaking that
there is not enough space so to speak
there's not enough degrees of freedom to
have all the particles come together and
manifest gravity with the particle of
charge electromagnetism the particles of
the weak force and the particles of the
strong force in four dimensions or they
go below it they go L they go above it
they they they say actually the space in
which things are happening is not four
we see four-dimensional space just like
we don't see the effects of protons
neutrons and electrons okay yeah but we
will see we will see the macroscopic
manifestation of uh of particles we see
their Collective Behavior we can't see
their individual Behavior they will say
you can't even see the individual
behavior of the dimensions because
they're they're so much smaller there
their thigh scales in which they operate
are so far removed from our
observability that's what I was talking
about go lower with the size yeah
exactly right so so you're effectively
uh talking about uh uh what are
different schemes called
compactification and so forth so you
have more than the four dimensions now
the question is is it five Dimensions
there were theories in other words you
could have a theory that would have
quantum mechanics and magnetism and
electricity and that actually could work
in a certain sense if SpaceTime had five
Dimensions um so if you added one more
Dimension it's kind of you'd have like
an electromagnetic Dimension and you can
almost see this with things like there
are birds or here's a good thing like
there there's three properties to light
like we're in this room there's certain
color of light there's a certain
intensity of light and there's something
called polarization which is the least
familiar property of Light which is how
the waves of electricity and magnetism
are Marching up and down left and right
or not at all okay yeah I never thought
about that building this thought about
the first two exactly it's totally
unfamiliar because we don't have to
detect that bees do bees do and there's
certain crystals that can have the sense
and birds do so they can navigate
there's certain navigational properties
that nature has embodied them to involve
to have such that they can navigate
using the not just the color and
intensity of the Sun but actually when
the sun is down they'll be able to
navigate based on the polarization of
the lights waves but anyway if you add
another dimension our eyes to our eyes
capability and and actually then we
could see this phenomena it would be
like yeah we're adding an extra
Dimension to SpaceTime so we'd have we'd
have super uh what do they call that
extra sensory perception six sense um so
so we don't have that technically
there's a tiny amount in certain people
but but anyway the mo average person
doesn't have it so when you uh think
about what they had to do they had to
say well well what is the U minimum
number of additional properties of the
universe that you'd have to add such
that it could manifest the properties
that you do want which is to have
quantum mechanics and gravity play
together nicely
and all operate as one single equation
one single force field and that was
found to be originally 26 you need 26
different dimensions of space and then
these these abstract spaces that we
can't by definition access because we're
we exist in three dimensions and even
particles of light only travel in three
dimensions of space in one in time so
you'd have to have some other way to
access these dimensions and and then the
obser the immediate observations is we
don't see any of these Dimensions so
there must be either way too big for us
to see we're just these tiny little ants
on the surface of a doughnut and we
don't know that the doughnut is curving
in this direction or that direction or
the um or it's the opposite where're
these enormous macroscopic creatures and
actually the SpaceTime is curved on
these phenomenally infinitesimally small
dimensions of 10 Theus 30th cenm that we
can also not access we can't detect them
there's no properties of particle
accelerator there's no microscope that
can zoom in as you say to see them real
quick to all my Discord people out there
the Julie Dory Discord is officially
live I put the link down in the
description below so go hit that join
the community and say what's up there's
all kinds of features in there and I
look forward to hearing from you guys
let's get it popping now what Whitten
did is he realized that there was a way
to reduce that number from 26 to 11 and
then it was reduced to 10 Dimensions how
um so this is truly Beyond even my
mathematical you know uh Concepts but uh
but effectively as I understand it the
comp ACAC ification was a recognition
that they the instantiation of these
particles the the properties of
particles or the properties of these
strings they didn't need to be have at
that many dimensions the original number
of dimensions and so this was basically
what one him the fields medal there's no
know about PR in mathematics the closest
thing is is called the fields medal and
it's it's awarded to people under 40 for
the greatest contribution uh to
mathematics and he want it for physics
basically for this for these kind of uh
laws and understanding how you could
reduce the dimension ity down to a more
tractable number I always say like over
the summer there was this big brewhaha
with um you know that Joe Rogan and Elon
Musk got all involved with which is that
this this new study confirms or says the
universe is 26 billion years old oh yeah
and I talked about this with Joe on his
show and it's really one guy who I know
he's a nice guy in Canada and he came
out with some model that seems to
suggest that yeah in certain
circumstances you could you could have a
universe that's older it would be needed
to be older in order to explain the
properties of galaxies that are much
much younger or Too Young in a universe
that's only 13 billion years old and for
people following out there we basically
go up the scale solar system galaxy
universe so he's looking at the whole
sheban clusters and galaxies between
that and then the universe so he was
looking at really as you look back in
space you're looking back in time so
light uh the only good thing about you
know using imperial units of feet and so
forth is that light travels one foot
every nanc so I'm seeing you 3 fet away
I'm seeing you not as you are
instantaneously right now I'm seeing you
three NS ago you look very young and
very vital and very healthy um but uh
but it's not instantaneous so as you
look back to the curtains behind you
those are six feet away so it's 6 n you
keep going go past you know New Jersey
Manhattan go all the way back to the the
center of the Milky Way go beyond the
Milky Way go to the local super cluster
eventually you're going to get back to
where there's nothing in your way no
buildings no planets no asteroids no
galaxies and there you're seeing back to
when the earliest galaxies themselves
are being formed if they exist and what
he what this regenda Gupta University of
Ottawa said was well based on my
calculations one person's calculations
you know bolster by you know he's didn't
make any errors or blunders but he sort
of came to the conclusion that the
Universe had to be much older we'll talk
about that later because that is a a a
proper controversy that we can discuss
um there are others that say the
universe is infinitely old so he's even
though it's twice the age of the
accepted universe that does come up with
it's still a hell of a lot you know
younger than an infinitely old universe
that this other guy Eric learner had
come up with about a year before that I
just don't know how you can and and this
is the total non-scientist take sitting
on the sidelines just looking at this
from the broadest lens you can I don't
know how you can possibly date something
that we H like we haven't reached the
limits of our solar system let alone the
Galaxy right and there's obviously
things that can go into how how physics
Works to say that we have things like
galaxies and and there are collections
of galaxies to form the collection of
galaxies and then the universe but like
to talk about the entire thing which
could
be infinite numerical values away from
us and to put a to put a a finite age on
it that that does not process for me
yeah well I can't I just want to correct
you with my trade mark love and
affection uh it can't be infinite if the
universe is not infinitely old yes okay
sorry there are people not necessarily
the highest respected scientist out
there um even working as professional
researchers just kind of pundit almost
that do say the universe is infinitely
old and a static and has never changed
there is abundant evidence that the
universe is not infinitely old and
infinitely static and infinitely
unchanging but they're to give them
their due they're in good company I mean
Einstein believed until 1929 that the
Universe was static effectively static
and in fact he injected into his famous
equations a term that would counteract
the gravitational collapse that he knew
as a brilliant man would be inevitable
for a universe that only has matter so I
told you before protons repel each other
a proton and an electron attract each
other because they're opposite charges
there's no such thing as negative
gravitational charge in other words
gravity is only attractive in our solar
system there's no gravitational
repulsion there's no like antimatter
that causes anti-gravity it doesn't push
you right so um so Einstein then
realized well I'm pretty smart I know we
live in a galaxy galaxy is made of stars
and gas and dust and planets um that's
matter that's only attractive how come
it's not collapsing in on itself how
come I'm here to ask the question of why
is there a Galaxy at all so he injected
into his equations of what's called
general relativity which corrected the
flaws in Newton's gravity in the same
process of going from Flat Earth to
spherical Earth to pear-shaped Earth Etc
that process is one of refinement you
start off with an idea you look for the
flaws in it then you look to find
evidence and an explanation for why
those flaws exist and how to correct
them to make a better approximation a
more accurate approximation and
hopefully one that's more precise so
what Einstein did is he said I'm going
to inject this fluid that fills the
universe called the cosmological
constant or the vacuum energy and that's
going to act like the pressure inside of
a balloon that keeps the universe
expanded out against gravitational
collapse of all the ordinary matter in
the universe and so he did that later
recanted it when he saw from Hubble that
every single Galaxy Hubble could see was
moving away from the Milky Way galaxy so
at first the very first thing he could
say was the universe is not static right
do you agree that in a universe where
things are moving that the universe is
not static is that I mean I'm asking you
yeah right so that torpedoed a
scientific idea that held sway for 2,000
years can I go back for one second just
to make sure I I didn't mix that up at
the end but when you were saying static
there was a lot in there when you were
saying static he's referring to it
didn't have necessarily beginning it
just always was all all I'm saying is
static means it's
unchanging it means that the only five
things they knew that moved are the
planets they didn't know about the other
things that were moving in the universe
up until you know Galileo and and and uh
us the telescope but you had said that
Einstein before he changed his opinion
on this had thought you know there
wasn't like a beginning that had a
Creator certainly didn't think that and
then he didn't even think that there was
something moving or expanding or
collapsing remember with when you have
when you have gravity and you have this
mysterious other force that could blow
up the universe or cause it to contract
slower or ultimately contract on itself
he wasn't thinking at all about uh about
the origin in the universe that wasn't
what was leading him he was looking at
the evidence and the evidence showed
that there were all these nebula which
they thought were outside or perhaps
even Inside the Milky Way galaxy and the
Milky Way galaxy wasn't collapsing in on
itself so forget about these other
Galaxies for a second although they're
The crucial key Insight that Hubble
provided to Einstein to reject his
original idea but looking at uh just the
Milky Way galaxy there are stars in the
Milky Way galaxy over 100 billion stars
they are not all collapsing together
even to the black hole at the middle of
the Milky Way galaxy what's causing them
not to do that well Einstein thought the
universe was the Milky Way galaxy and he
said there must be some Force some
pressure that's keeping them perfectly
balanced which is very weird right now
it turns out Julian not to blow your
mind it is true that there is a fluid
that does keep the Universe um inflated
against collapse on itself but it's
doing too much uh inflation it's
actually causing the universe to expand
exponentially faster over time so
tomorrow's expansion rate the Galaxy
that's at a certain distance away from
us is going to be farther tomorrow and
it's going to be accelerating away from
us at a greater rate than it is today
but Ein said didn't know that back then
so you know I to be honest with you I've
I've committed the ultimate you know
podcaster you know cardinal sin so I
don't remember what got us on the
subject but just to say that um in
gravity with these unification you know
back going back to string theory perhaps
that's what we were doing we were doing
String Theory the ultimate goal would be
to explain why is the universe expanding
like this why are the ultimate uh
building blocks of nature the very
smallest things in nature that we know
about why are they um uh responsible for
the large scale behavior of the universe
and you mentioned um I think which did
get me on this tangent it's
incomprehensible how do we even know the
universe we hav't only gone to the you
know we've only sent people to the moon
like how are we how can we say something
about a Galaxy that's 100 billion light
years away um uh or less than that but
the point is is that in in science you
have to do the following you have to
have a some idea of the current best
guess for the composition and dynamics
of the universe and then you have to ask
a question what is it about the universe
that I can predict um will happen
tomorrow based on the evidence today M
and then using that same inductive
framework yesterday if I was a scientist
yesterday knowing what I knew only
yesterday not today what would I
predicted about the universe today and
then you keep iterating that process
backwards to the Past into the future
and you ask do I reach a Terminus do I
reach a point in which there is no way
to go back further in time to the past
or to the Future which would point to
Creation a big bang or an origin of time
or an or a collapse of a previous
Universe into the raw constituents of
our current universe and all these
models have had ideas from Antiquity to
today I mean I was reading about an
Egyptian cosmology from the year 1000
BCE that's basically a cyclical universe
that comes in and out of existence and
you know and there are models that have
been static you know Aristotle to Newton
to Einstein believe the universe was
static unchanging and then the question
is given the evidence that you have
today can you falsify any of those
narrative narratives yes we can falsify
many many hundreds of thousands of of of
cosmogeny Origins Genesis of the
universe models for it and what's left
is a handful a small handful but we
can't do that with string theory we
can't really say well based on the
evidence this is incompatible with
string theory and it's compatible with
geometric Unity so that when I do what I
do my job is to again not prove these
brilliant men and women right it's to
hopefully falsify as many of them as
possible so I ask Eric all the time
comes and visits he gives lectures I go
see him uh you know Steven wlfr and I
talk frequently we're going to talk
again soon uh I'd love to talk with that
guy yeah he yeah he's a brilliant guy
yeah he's up in Massachusetts uh you
know well we'll see he he's kind of a
night owl so it might be you know like
midnight on a Tuesday love we'll get
some liquor FL the whole
de so my job is uh to always Hector
these people and say to them what is it
that I can can turn my $100 million plus
tell $100 million plus Simon's
Observatory on what can you sick the
dogs of experimental physics on to get
out the
falsification the disproof of what
you're saying because they're good
scientists so they'll say well I predict
that there's you know so Eric's theory
has some unique predictions one is that
it has two dimensions of time two not
just one di how does that work so this
is a reason you know for you to chat
with him at some point but the the in
the manifestation of two dimensions in
time allows for um is an additional
dimension in the same way that wht's 10
dimensions are additional dimensions of
space so you should no more ask why why
two dimensions of time than why are
there you know only three dimensions of
space why aren't there uh why can't you
move back why aren't there two
dimensions of time right now in other
words why is it possible that there
couldn't be S so-called what are called
closed Loops that you in certain
trajectories you could make an Excursion
in time at and there were people that
belied this about the standard mod you
know way before Eric that proposed
multi-dimensional time he's not the
first person to propose it and that that
that time property has to have different
behaviors the second dimension of time
that then dovetail with the ordinary
behavior of our current Arrow of time
and that would imply also and am I
incorrect in saying that would imply you
could manipulate the motion of time um
I'm not sure exactly how it it it would
be you know uh certainly that you could
perhaps make excursions I say you could
take paths and there are trajectories
that a person or an entity or particle
could have again we're not talking about
people these could be very compactified
as well um so so then the question is
well how could you verify or validate
that um how could you validate that
there's there's only three dimensions of
space how can you validate that gravity
travels at the same speed as as ordinary
time or ordinary light does and so these
are questions that I ask them and only
in certain theories will you get an
answer uh and and it turns out Eric's
Theory makes other predictions that are
a little bit more testable than this
than these compactified Dimensions um
the particle inventory of how many
particles there are in the universe is
uh is a measurable quantity in other
words we don't know all the particles
that could possibly exist so how's it
measurable if we don't know because they
have other properties in addition to
like their names or whatever we call
them uh for example they have intrinsic
properties called spin mass and charge
but couldn't there be particles far
beyond what we can visibly understand
that we wouldn't even know how they
would exist cuz we don't understand how
that would work well at a certain level
you could always say that because you
could say but I could also say couldn't
there be God or or couldn't there be a
poltergeist or couldn't there you know
so couldn't there be but then the
question is well how come I always ask
like how come these Poltergeist and and
what and near-death experiences and so
how come they ma they don't manifest
themselves with an interaction with the
Ordinary World or they only do for
certain people right so these particles
let's say call it the Poltergeist
particle theory all right so this
Poltergeist particle does have an
interaction in his theory or will have a
manifestation even though it may not
exist to this day it may have decayed
away it may no longer exist but because
his theory makes definitive predictions
about the inventory of these particles
which again only have every particle is
fungible right like one electron is as
good as any other electron if it has the
same properties it has a spin an angular
momentum a charge and a mass you can
swap one out for the other you'll never
if I swapped every electron in your body
out with another electron or here's
another symmetry if I swapped every
proton neutron and electron in your body
out with its antimatter equivalent you
would I mean I wouldn't exist because
you'd annihilate you know everything in
this room but you could exist I mean
there could be completely antimatter
versions of this we've even seen that
gravity affects antimatter identical to
the way it affects ordinary matter and
some models of of string theory or other
models other alternative unification
ideas do not feature that so every time
time you do a test it can be used to
exclude the properties of a hypothesized
new Force interaction or particle and
that's where it's valuable to be the you
know Roosevelt's man in the arena that's
actually making predictions and that's
why I get so flued and frustrated and
upset when you hear theorists who are a
lot closer to it than Brian keading is
they say I don't have time to look at
your theory yes what else are you doing
it's been 50 years you know as you said
string theory has been around for 50
years uh there people making refinements
upon refinements on refinements of it
why not spend some of your time
dedicated to either what particle
physicists could do what experimental
cosmologists could do and if you say
there's nothing there's no way to to
test this then that's a you problem
right I mean it's not it's not up to
it's not up to me to think about ways
that I could be able to test geometric
unity and it happens to be that he as I
said he makes certain predictions uh
with colleagues we there are ways to
bridge the gap between the phenomena
that he's proposing with the
experimental observables that my team
and I can observe and then test those
and hopefully rule out as much as
possible but again never with the goal
of proving yeah I there's a lot of ego
that goes into anything where there's
High Intelligence it's just the nature
of the Beast you look throughout human
history it's never been different but I
I did ask Mito about that when he was in
here do you believe in god well I
believe in the god of Einstein he
believed in God but not the god that
intervenes in human Affairs it was the
god of order the god of Simplicity and
elegance Einstein was asked the question
did the universe have a choice is it
unique so universes you can create
universes in an afternoon but most of
them are unstable most of them fall
apart most of them don't work our
universe is stable it works everything
fits together and then the question is
what's set off the bang that's what we
do for a living we have the Big Bang
Theory up to the point where the
universe is going to explode why did it
explode we think it was a Quantum event
and we are here because we are in the
universe which decided to explode so
Einstein said was it all an accident and
he thought no it could not have been an
accident towards the end I I asked him
something along the lines of would you
be upset if all your work in your life
was proven wrong or would you be happy
to know that that's kind of the whole
point of it in the first place and I
don't want to say what he said because
I'll I'll get it wrong but his answer
was very very well thought it wasn't as
much like no look I I want to be right
about this or I want to be mostly right
about it and if I'm not you know it all
goes away and to me when you look across
a lot of Science and you could talk
about this with the disagreement he may
have with Weinstein in this case where
maybe he's not looking at it or
something like that but when you look
across science there's so much tied to
if you are are told you're wrong that
means that you provided no value to in
my opinion though we can study these
guys from history we can study the
Einstein and and the concepts that they
came up with and if it's all proven
wrong but that that incorrectness
actually unlocked a layer for us to look
at to be able to get a step farther then
to me that's that makes their work
beautiful that makes it the whole point
of like the definition of the word
itself and and also say like wrong or
right you're acting and I'm not saying
I'm just saying one is acting as if
science is what's called a finite game
so I don't know Carol D has this notion
of infinite and finite games um I think
it's her it might be somebody else but
anyway she oh she has the growth mindset
versus the fixed mindset D you said uh
Carol dck but it's actually look up
infinite game Simon synic wrote a book
about it but he's not the one who uh who
identified it first so there's something
a concept called the infinite game it's
something where there are clear players
clear rules a beginning a middle and an
end and a winner and a loser chess is
paradigmatic of this okay so um when you
have a finite game there's a winner and
a loser when you have an infinite game
the object of an infinite game is to
keep playing and the infinite game uh is
very much akin to science science cannot
be one but the paradoxical thing is that
science is comprised of an innumerable
finite games let me mention one uh
undergraduate getting into college like
you got into some undergraduate college
that means someone else didn't right
then you get into graduate school then
you do what's called a post talk then
you might be uh another postu then you
might be an assistant professor then you
have to get tenure not everyone so all
these hurdles all these I call it the
academic Hunger Games because you're
like fighting against these people and
tribute to you know basically your own
career of what you want to do in science
and then getting grants is even harder
and then getting Publications right so
winner and a loser but at all these
levels and yet what's the ultimate game
that you're playing you're playing an
infinite game you can't win science
there's no such thing so when somebody
says well I hope that I'm right or I
hope that I'm wrong they are treating
science as if it's an infinite a finite
game and I think that's fundamentally
misconstrued so I don't remember what
Mito said but uh but it's natural as it
let's be frank it's not if I said to you
oh it's great you know if I get
falsified you know and I'm proven wrong
or I in a blunder or I did something
dumb you know like oh it's great I'll
write another book no obviously as a
human being you know and you often hear
this about uh about projects like the
Large Hadron Collider or building
another version of super Hadron Collider
around the circumference of the Moon you
know you hear these things that there
could be future things that cost
trillions of dollars right and it's
probably not likely to happen uh and
some people say oh the most interesting
thing would be if we never see if we
don't see what we expected if we never
saw the higs Bo on at the large that
would have been so excited I'm like no
it wouldn't be it would be 20 30 billion
euros wasted you know in thousands of of
hours in people's lives I mean you're
dealing with people's lives I think
that's part of the problem with ER that
Eric has with people like Whitten and
even the the ideology of Kaku or what
have you that they see see monom
manically focused on one thing being
right and everything else being wrong
and they don't explore as far as I'm
aware I have yet to see a paper of by
say Ed Whitten where he's looking and
trying to explore the intricacies of a
rival Theory called not Eric's Theory uh
but it's called Loop quantum gravity
Carlo relli and Lee smullen brilliant
people that promulgated this fora AST
car brilliant Brilliant Minds I haven't
seen like a debate between those two I
think people want to see Eric you know
fight it out with mitcho uh although I
wasn't clear from the interview if if
mitchu had any idea who Eric was so the
full story there is actually a little
bit funny yeah so I I do I'm not a
gotcha guy I know right I don't do the
whole you're walking into a buz saw here
and I'm going to no not at all not at
all that's not my job you want to go to
like CBS or ABC or Fox News or CNN go do
that but with when when he came in and
we were setting up the studio and
everything I didn't really think about
it I just casually asked him oh did you
see cuz it it was kind of funny like
let's be honest like like Eric Weinstein
is is Mitch okaku is out of control he
involuntarily funny as [__] I think he
knows what he's doing and so like the
way he said it he's just sitting there
and sometimes I feel like he's having a
like especially when he's on with Joe
like he's just having a conversation
with himself and Joe's just like okay
like I don't know but he's sitting there
and out of nowhere he's like meuk Kaku
get meuk Kaku in here with me meuk
kaku's out of control he's he like
staring at Joe and Joe's like why he's
like's he's doing this he's doing that
and so I said to Meo I said you know
what did you think of that you know do
do you think there's valid criticism or
whatever and he looks me dead in the
eyes and he goes who said this and I and
I go Eric Weinstein he he was talking
about this on Joe Rog you've been on Joe
Rogan before right and he goes yes but
who who is this person and I'm like Eric
Weinstein the mathematician do you think
he was like um belittling Eric not at
all he just no idea I want to be so
clear isn't that a problem Julian isn't
that a problem that you don't know who
your Chief I'm not saying you have to
respond to every troll or whatever or do
everything but um but that you don't
know who they are necessarily and um and
and that be speaks again he asked for it
though to be clear like like like he
said he said I don't know who this is
and he was like can can you show me this
right and then he said oh can't s heat
let's get in the kitchen and then I
replied well I'm happy to provide the
you know the utensils and and the Gordon
Ramsey like experience as your impartial
host and I I've had both of them on
obviously I liked I've been on mito's
podcast I've been on Eric's although he
never published it all right sorry about
that we should be good now but we were
we were talking about how Kaku didn't
know about what some of the critics were
saying and and I'm I'm sorry if your
point got cut off there but yeah I do
want to be clear there was no there was
Zero like like oh who the [__] is that
there none of that he was he asked to
look at it and then he was like it was
hilarious watching him like turn to the
TV and like intently watch and I my
friend's looking at me going like this
behind cut cut cut like this is too much
but he watched it for like 90 seconds
and he's like what I'd have to look at
the theory but he's like if you can't
take heat don't come in kitchen and I
was like oh my
God [__] hilarious um when he was uh
when I think when he was saying that it
did did seem like well maybe he'd be
open to it uh maybe he wouldn't um but
look at it uh there's a a famous quote I
think from Richard Dawkins you know and
you say uh there's somebody wants to
debate you you know Professor keading or
you know Professor Dawkins you're wrong
about Evolution he goes I can see how
that would look really good on your CV
you I can see how it look really bad on
my CV right so I so there's this sort of
risk aversion for people you know that
have gotten to the level of a wit and
you know Fields medalist is he going to
talk to Brian keading I mean he's turned
down my any request to talk right
Whitten has yeah but he hasn't he
doesn't really talk on stuff right no I
mean he'll go he talk with that one guy
I for yeah he's talked with gram felo
was a friend whose I've had him um and
that's fine you know he's he's he's
moved away I mean he's been getting into
more esoteric actually related to
astrophysics rather than you know string
theory and stuff like that in recent
years but again you know if you look at
their publication records and and you
say well like what are these theories
doing how many papers are they putting
out how many students are they advising
how many conferences are they going to
speak at you know um do they truly not
have time to look at I mean there's only
like two or three theories that have
come up that are you know plausible
Challengers and I've had them on and I
also hold them to account Carlo relli
look this result from you know these
these quazars at a at a distance of you
know a billion Lighty years they seem to
be inconsistent with the discretization
of of loop quantum gravity what do you
have to say about that oh that's a good
idea you know but like I'm sure that he
knows I'm sure Carlo and Eric and um
gett leasy and Steven Wolfram are more
than familiar with string theory and the
question I always have is why is the
converse true why don't these other
people have an understanding or the
limitations of just some of the basics
and Eric points these out all the time
you know why are there you know three
generations of ferons why are there you
know uh no spin three Hales particles
and so there lacune flaws in stry
everybody knows that what flaws laun or
lack lack gaps there are gaps in the
educ science turns man trying to throw
right above me I'm from Jersey you got
to you got to go slower okay well you
know what they call the Holland Tunnel
right you know $20 is a cheap price to
go New Jersey I just kid I kid because I
love the origin of the universe was
discovered here in newey edicine was
might have stole some tech was Tesla
here Tesla was here yeah yeah that's the
guy he might stole from he could be
right we got both of them so they were
Rivals right so you see this you see
these now that's in a thing where
there's not only intellectual um stakes
and and bounties right there's Financial
tremendous Financial bounties right um
and that uh and you know as well as ego
and stuff so when you look at the the
landscape of it I always want to just
ask here's a rubric here's a checklist
here's if I'm talking to my students I I
ask them here's what you have to do to
get you know like you have to do a
certain amount of homework you have to
participate in class you have to do um
you know uh discussion sections if you
want to get extra you know so there's a
whole list of things that they have to
do for string theory what would it have
to do what phenomena would it have to
explain and the beauty is that all these
things have the same job they all arey
try to explain the fundamental linkage
of gravity with the other forces of
nature but again again you don't see
these people so let's say that they
can't attest to string theory they can't
there's no way that you can prove or
disprove String Theory other than
getting 30 orders magnitude you know
range in the mass of the electron say as
C bafa told me um let's say you can't do
that why aren't the same people working
on a grand unified theory which you can
test you could test it with a large
hedron collider in other words there are
ways to test that well there are C
certain I mean how deep you want to get
into like how particle colliders work
and so forth so you can okay so if you
have if I show you collisions between a
bowling ball and um and a crystal ball
right you can learn things about uh
about the properties of the materials
each one is made up by how they behave
when they interact with each other
depending on the speed so you shoot them
together at one inch per hour nothing's
going to happen you shoot them at one
you know uh one kilometer per second
something is going to happen when that
when that occurs right so depending on
then you learn well the strength of the
materials one is stronger than the other
one is more massive than the other you
learn about the shrapnel that tells you
about the materials properties the
chemistry right so the analog here with
particles particles don't have chemistry
they they're they're particle physics
right so you learn about the
interactions are they interacting at a
um at the level of 10 Theus 10 cenm how
strong is the interaction between these
particles what is their cross-section
are there other particles participating
adding to the Dynamics of the Collision
the shrapnel that comes out from them
all those things you can can learn from
particle accelerators and again what
we're trying to do in the grand unified
theory and test your knowledge right is
not unify with gravity which could
require the entire universe to test
right they're testing the properties of
particles the unification of electricity
and magnetism the weak nuclear force in
the strong nuclear force to to my mind
that's an unsolved problem it's right
there for the picking but guess what you
don't get maybe the same Glory as you
know you don't get to be put in the same
book you know that has the god equation
as its title Einstein and Kaku and
Whitten and it is marketed very well
like the the the what they're trying to
get
at to leave off with Einstein's work
that was left on his desk the marketing
of we're looking for reading the mind of
God I mean yeah how do you beat that
right you know yeah and there's a very
it's much more quotable to say that than
I'm looking for the uh the reaction
cross-section in Barns between a muon
and a uh and and a positron you just
don't get the attention for doing that
well the the big problem here as we laid
out earlier on in this podcast is that
we're still at a point here in late 2023
where we it's not testable to do string
theory and I feel like looking at it
from the
outside part of that holding on to it
and and putting an emphasis on string
theory being the having the most
potential to be correct is the fact that
there is this multigenerational weight
to see when we can test it so do you
think it's possible that if we get to
like Quantum Computing or something like
that we will be able to test something
particles that small that would that
would be a part of string theory I
actually don't know if it requires new
technology it may in the sense that uh
when we start to look at the uh the the
earliest moments of the universe the
best collider that you can get is the
one with the most energy because when
you smash these things together you're
inter you're showing not only the cons
constituents the chemistry of the
bowling ball and the and the crystal
ball right you're also exploring what
Freedom do these particles have to move
in different directions and that's
that's part of what these particle
accelerators get out now the particle
accelerator that the largest one ever
built is a large hydron collider it's
about 27 kilomet in circumference it
goes between France and and
Switzerland and uh it's it's an
incredible Monument to the technology
and the physics of the 21st century it's
where they higs Bon was discovered but
very little else uh there are other
experiments there not related to finding
new properties about the higs and when I
say they found the higs that means that
they measured the three properties of a
particle the fungible three that are the
mass and the charge and the spin of a
particle that's really it's on its
license plate that's what each one of
these things has and nothing else so
again each one is interchangeable so
they discovered what is the charge of
the higs BOS on which was Zero what is
the mass of the higs BOS on which some
number 125 Giga electron volts um with
accuracy in other words it previously
been a maximum limit like when I said
your 1,000 kilograms it was like your
125 26 kgr at the upper end and your 124
kgrs at the lower very precise very
precisely and it's gotten better and
better with time but that's really it I
mean you know these are heroic
contributors had on Harry Cliff who's is
an amazing uh young scientist many
people from the higs collab from people
that worked on the LHC rather
uh part of it's LED from UC San Diego um
and uh where I am and and two different
experiments measured exactly the same
results it's a beautiful thing and these
are billions of dollars worth of
experiments and tens of thousands of
people's career years so uh I don't want
to dismiss it or cast any it's an heroic
accomplishment but to date that 20
billion project when you include the
Construction Plus operating it for over
a decade and the upgrades to it has been
you know tremendously underwhelming I
think of most physicists not because
they didn't do a good job just that's
all that they were able to access with
that level of microscopy of looking at
the finest scale interactions between
these things we don't believe that any
collider like our current generation
collider can do it but the biggest
collider there could ever be is when the
first moments of the universe produce
the first particles energy forces and
Fields and that's the kind of topics
that my colleagues and I are trying to
you're getting to the big bang with this
yeah so the Big Bang is is basically in
term that we use for multiple things one
is the formation of the universe I.E the
beginning of time one is the earliest
Epoch in the universe that we can apply
known laws of physics to um and that uh
and that could be you know because of
limitations in our understanding of
physics or could be in limitations of
what is possible to know in other words
there may not have been any moment
before the Tuesday in which the Big Bang
occurred or what have you so looking at
the um looking at the universe as a
collider and then looking at the
shrapnel that comes off of that collider
namely the artifacts the fossils that
have persisted throughout time just in
the same way that you know the Raiders
of Lost Arc the there's a fossil there's
a relic you know the Lost Arc it's
traveled through space and time to get
to us today and we can make models about
well how is it formed where did it come
from and what have you or a T-Rex SK
skeleton you know we can make models of
how old it is how um how it was formed
um maybe how many other such objects
exist the same thing we do with this
meteorite that you get on my weite it or
that I gave to you as a great cost four
billion years baby let's go so you make
models and then you can test them we can
do the same thing we can ask questions
what is the earliest Epoch that we have
physical evidence from what are those
pieces of evidence and what can the
archaeology of SpaceTime tell us about
not only what those conditions were like
back then but what will happen in the
Deep future of our universe and that's
kind of uniquely the purview of
cosmology we've never done a particle
like we've never detected I shouldn't
we've never what are called cosmic rays
particles from the Sun or from Supernova
or these are like protons and electrons
accelerated near the speed of light a
single particle with the energy of a you
know of a of um I was going to say Nolan
Ryan but I don't really gave me I'll say
no Ryan can
still j j j Jake snow okay Padres right
okay hopefully sa young or I don't know
if you won the S Young or not but anyway
uh a fast ball a single particle with
the energy of a fast ball from Major
League baseball pit okay these are
discovered they were discovered in space
or on balloons on the earth in 1920s and
30s um but those are some of the only
particle properties that we ever
discovered using astronomical technology
but now almost without uh disagreement
the future discoveries in partical
physics will come from cosmology and
astrophysics the part the properties
there there is a type of part there are
only 17 so-called ele particles that's a
particle you can't chop into another
particle um a proton can be chopped into
quart s right we can't chop up the
quarks um a a neutron also into quarks
an electron cannot be chopped into
anything what strength Theory will say
oh no it's a manifestation of vibration
of a string right but we don't know that
for sure but so what we know there's 17
of them including the higs BOS on that
can't be destroyed or reduced further so
they're called elements Elementary
particles there are three of them
they're called neutrinos we know that
the neutrinos have mass that they weigh
a little bit actually they're the
lightest of the known particles uh but
we know what that mass is with
experiments like the Simon Observatory
and other astronomical observatories we
can constrain and actually detect the
mass of these wispy ghost particles of
which trillions are going through us
every day um from nuclear reactions on
the from the Sun and throughout the
cosmos so we're going to measure for the
first time with a telescope the
properties of something that used to be
measured with a microscope another like
like a a particle accelerator it'll be
as if we're going to learn about DNA
from uh looking looking at uh you know
through an x-ray telescope it it kind of
should blow your mind right we're going
to learn about the building blocks of
nature by looking through a telescope
like the ultimate tiniest things we no
we learn about them from the universe as
a particle accelerator laboratory and
effectively uh an a grand experiment on
which every property of every particle
plays out so it's it's quite exciting
time to be a cosmologist in
particular it's wild how much Innovation
we have out there that like guys like me
never even think about and even when you
listen to podcast you're only touching
the surface of what everyone in the
world is working on it's it's just crazy
to me and I'm I'm sure it's way crazier
to you harder when you're in the field
right but do you ever you know we we we
touched a little bit on Creation in this
conversation so far but not like
specifically do you ever just get
stressed out about not knowing where it
all began as a scientist everyone thinks
about this to be clear obviously it's
the meaning of life but as a scientist
where you're you're trying to to find
your way there does it ever just like
you're like holy [__] like it crashes in
on you a little bit um I don't I don't
have as many of those you know kind of
moral quandaries or crises of of faith I
think it's because of something I heard
you know in the saying something like
you know in the in the a poor person has
you know basically a rich man has many
many worries and a poor man only has one
or a sick man only has one wish right so
I think the crisis of of sort of you
know meaning uh is a luxury that one
will have and not saying you're some
entitled person but by the byproduct of
of how amazing it has been for
civilization to have relative periods of
freedom and peace where we're at Liberty
to just do things that are useless that
don't actually create GDP or you know
directly impact a cure for some disease
or something like that so um in my
estimation I have I'm so busy concerned
with Logistics of day-to-day activities
of trying to get this student to get his
PhD uh trying to teach this class of
undergraduates trying to you know
prepare this paper uh for publication
and you know these these things take so
much time trying to get people to a
telescope to take data uh so that we can
release it and publish the findings so
the funding agencies will keep
supporting us and we can keep developing
expanding and making you know new
inroads and so forth so as an
experimentalist I don't really have the
luxury to sit around and think about oh
well you know what does it all mean now
as a religious person as somebody who is
a practicing Jew and does uh proceed to
think about the ultimate meaning of life
on a daily basis multiple times a day in
fact then uh I do question how people
don't come up with those moral and
existential crises and and I kind of
hinted at it before in the context of
theoretical you know scientists versus
experimental scientists in that you know
all of what we do is you know it may be
important but it may not be significant
like the average thing that you know is
it going to really change the world I
feel that way by the way about like
celebrities or you know people even
people that I you know are they
important yes are they significant you
know is a Kardashian like changing the
future of the world I don't know not
maybe maybe to you know someone who
likes uh uh skims or whatever right uh
she's got a lot of good merch I envy
that uh but um but by the same token you
know if you don't think about the
existential questions then you shouldn't
be a scientist if it never occurs to you
that what you're trying to do is unveil
the ultimate building blocks of nature
that have been hidden uh for the
entirety of human existence up until now
and you have a right to be a part of
that and you don't question it or think
about the big picture I think there's
almost should feel evocative of of
embarrassment that you're just basically
doing a technical trade which is
beautiful I love technicians I've I used
to work on you know old cars I still do
um I love technical things you know I
don't love Plumbing gu so to do but
there I'm not denigrating that at all
but those people their jobs are not to
think about the origin existentialism
and yet your job is in a certain sense
now should that lead to a you know
feeling of panic I don't necessarily
think so I think it should be it should
energize without enervating it you
shouldn't be irrit ated about it but
likewise I get uh I get you know kind of
amused or uh you know just find it a
little bit uh silly when you hear people
that are you know that will talk about
well because we're so small in the
universe that actually gives me great
comfort because like our lives are
basically meaningless compared to the
vast expanse of History the future
unknowable domain and the size of things
in the universe that make us basically
you know this this spec of dust you know
uh floating in in on a Sunbeam right I I
think that's uh grandiose I think that's
false humility I don't know anyone who
acts like that like oh I'm not going to
pay my taxes because what is it you know
what is like you know it's uh you know
like Annie Hall when uh Alie is a as a
young man and and he won't do his
homework and he says I'm not doing my
homework mom and his mom takes him to a
therapist the therapist says Alie why
aren't you doing your homework and he
goes because the whole universe is
expanding and after billion years the
universe will rip apart and everything
and his mother goes shut up you idiot
Brooklyn is not expanding um so it's
true you have to balance that you know
you have to balance the grandios with
the with the quotidian with the daily
kind of activities and to me you know
the the my job is this Ideal Balance
between the two I get to do what I love
uh I would do it for fre I did do it for
free for you know most of my childhood
have a telescope look up make images
make sketches you know develop ideas and
theories for Stuff learn about the
calculus behind the orbits of of
comments that I was seeing and stuff
like that it really got me into it never
did I once think it could be a job you
know that could pay me and that payment
would be you know uh the payment and and
the additional payment that I believe I
Reed for my channel and doing Outreach
to the public who ultimately pay our
salaries as as professors and I don't
care where you are you could be at
Harvard or you could be at U you know
Cal State San Marcos or whatever you
still are making a difference because of
the laress of the American taxpayer at a
certain level in your education so to me
to not give back and not explore so my
podcast is where I scratch that itch of
the
existentialism the the theoretical the
philosophical I'm going to speak to a
philosopher later today a philosopher of
physics David Albert wman Manhattan
Brian Green those are the chances that
you get to talk about the real
meaningful things the people that I want
to to talk to and then there are people
I have to talk to you know there are
people at you know different government
bureaucracies and you campus uh you know
campus Administration I have to deal
those are not people yeah that I want to
talk to I like you know it's funny
because my wife's like oh well I love
you know I'm always like oh why don't
you just call an instacart she's like no
I like to go to the supermarket I'm like
oh yeah so if our neighbor called you
and said like I'll pay you five bucks to
go to the supermarket for me you go and
do it like you kind of rationalize stuff
that you like to do I know I have to do
that there's committee work and it's
funny because as a professor I thought
as a kid when I thought about what
professors did I was like oh they're
just sitting around you know they're
stroking their beards or they're looking
through telescopes all day and I'm like
on telecons you know way more than I'm
on telescopes and and that's kind of
unfortunate you know for the young kid
version of me um but I uh luckily get to
kind of um you know embellish and and
delve into that other side of my
character when I get to do podcast and
be on podcast like this very uh you know
uh an honor to be here today so oh I'm
happy to have you I I just it's very
fascinating when I get to speak with
guys who a part of what they do as you
laid it out there is is to think about
these things you know and and I I will
admit I have the luxury I guess of
thinking about it sometimes usually it's
late at night when my thoughts aren't so
quiet and I'm trying to make them quiet
and then of course I start thinking
about well what is nothing why is that
nothing has to be something in order for
nothing to exist and then the Edibles
kicking that's it that's even without
the edbl man I'm thinking about it
sometimes but you know
it's it it is it's the ultimate question
we all have what happens when the lights
turn off and when we're not here and
what we're doing and if there's there
were ever a scientific way to prove that
it it'd be pretty [__] incredible
yeah but you know to to look at your own
background and and what kind of where
you've been I I know you laid out a lot
of your childhood and story when you
were with Joe Rogan so I I don't want to
go through all of it here like people
can listen to that you did a great job
with that but you you were adopted into
a Catholic Family you later became
Jewish but somewhere along the way you
were atheist and now you consider
yourself agnostic and I was thinking
about that while you were answering that
question because it seemed to me like
you were maybe implying that there was
something at the beginning so how for
people out there who aren't as familiar
with with agnosticism what what is that
and and and what does that mean to you
yeah agnosticism kind of arose as a
middle ground perhaps between the purely
the theist conception where you know
there are just people that have ultimate
faith and and they they almost you know
faith transcends into belief uh almost
at the level of evidence and and direct
encounter with with Jesus or God or or
whoever um and then they're The Atheist
which means not theist so you're defined
by what you're not which is kind of
strange and then there's this Middle
Ground of of folks called agnostics
which means that it's not knowable
gnosticism is a sect or an ideology that
suggests that you know there are truths
that are knowable uh what you know
eschatological what happens in the Deep
future end times or you know after death
um you know the one of my kids was
asking me what happens you know what did
I look like before I was born I'm like
what the like where that children's
Flintstones chewable edible uh no I
don't do that uh but but looking at uh
these big picture topics thinking as a
scientist what is knowable via the
scientific method in other words what
when I said before uh you can make up
whatever Theory you want but if it
doesn't interact with the standard model
of particle physics with gravity with
forces and Fields and and and and
particles that we know about then it
it's just literally you know complete
esoteric sestry and philosophy right and
that's what some people accuse string
theory of and then there's a counter
reaction that no it'll actually make
predictions we just don't have enough
energy to get to them okay let's leave
that aside uh but um but if you if you
say something like God like does God God
exists so so a theologically inclined
person will say God exists he intervenes
he's a personal God yeah I'm talking
about judeo-christian God it's the only
one I'm familiar with but um but uh he
interacts in the physical world well
then there should be some physic you
should be able to build a large you know
Hashem a large you know God collider you
know you should be able to see well no
but but they'll say well no no he
interacts in other ways and and changes
laws and so forth um and that's what
prayer does prayer has an effect an
immaterial effect right there's no um
you know cranial functional uh magnetic
resonance imaging helmet I can put on
meas you can't say that that has an
effect you can see that things light up
in the brain differently when you do
that that's well-known fact and you can
even say what is the influence on
people's happiness and their
charitability and the and the and the
way that they live and those are all
functional benefits of being actively
the theistic now to me what I call
myself as a practicing agnostic not just
an agnostic so an agnostic will say I
don't know but practicing means but I'm
searching for evidence so if you say you
don't know you're an agnostic or that
it's unknowable there's one of two
options for you right you can say I am
going to act as if I don't know which
would mean you know that's the way a
good scientist should approach things
and say well let me investigate the two
Alternatives right so I can investigate
atheism which I have done and I was
atheist for many many years and I can
investigate theism or practicing in a
religion right so let's say and I
interviewed my first guest ever on the
in impossible podcast was a renowned
Titan physics who did truly lose the
Nobel Prize named Freeman Dyson the
Dyson Sphere is like the one what do you
mean he lost the Nobel Prize and that he
was co-inventor of some of the theory
associated with Quantum electrodynamics
that Richard fan did win the Nobel Prize
for but there were three other two other
people who won the Nobel Prize that year
and the Nobel Prize has these stupid
rules put into place not by Alfred Nobel
but by some Committee of Swedish
scientists back in early days of the NOA
that only allowed three people to win it
so he wow but it's totally arbit there's
nothing special but three you know what
they do any mey mo they uh just excluded
him they just gave it to two other guys
Fineman and two other guys um schwinger
and Tonga and they definitely deserved
it but Freeman deserved it as well
anyway he never complained about it and
uh he was a gentleman until he died uh
2020 but the uh but I talked to him on
my podcast the first time because he
called himself an agnostic and he had
won there's a prize called the Templeton
prize which is endowed by John Templeton
of you know Franklin Templeton fund and
other to be always worth a little bit
more than the Nobel Prize and it's for
showing the consilience or the
reconcilability of religion and science
that's why he endowed it and he made it
more prestigious Hope by making it worth
more money so Freeman had won it many
years ago like 20 years 30 years ago and
when he was on my podcast I asked him
well like what do you consider yourself
and he's like I'm an agnostic and I said
okay so um do you go to church and he
was like no I'm I told you I'm an
agnostic and I'm like wait but you're an
agnostic so if if some brilliant alien
you know is looking as cruising by and
my friend AI loes amua right and the
alien's looking down and it sees Richard
Dawkins or Lawrence Krauss you know
upcoming guest on this podcast past
guest on my podcast um and you see
Lawrence Krauss self- declared militant
atheist and and Lawrence is not going to
church because he never goes to church
he never goes to synagogue never goes to
Temple or whatever and then he sees
Freeman Dyson how could that alien
intelligent as he
a whatever you call it whatever it's
pronoun happen space pronoun is how
could you functionally distinguish
between those two people and he said you
can't there's no way because they're not
practicing anything they're not doing
the agnostic and Freeman was not doing
anything he was just kind of living off
the interest that he had accured as a
young man when he did go to church and
and and and and actually to give him his
credit he did he would sometimes go to
some fellowship Quakers or what have you
and he was not anti- anti-religious but
he wasn't actively pursuing the search
for truth and knowledge so did you start
referring to yourself as an agnostic
when you started practicing Judaism uh
that's a good question I think only in
retrospect do I realize that's what I'm
doing now and I should say I practicing
to me means like eating kosher food you
know because so I was born into a Jewish
Family parents divorced as you said uh
adopted by an Irish Catholic guy uh grew
up in his family amazing family became
so enthralled and in love with uh
Catholicism that I became an alter boy
never had a bar mitzvah in fact I just
had my bar mitzvah in Israel and thank
you toar in Israel in September and that
was an amazing time to be there as it
would uh be very difficult to do that
right now as you know um wow you were
there right I was there the week or two
before yeah and uh we talk about that
later but but um so practicing it so I
did these things I learned to speak
Hebrew I learned to read Hebrew um I
wanted to understand this whole Legacy
that I had been gifted and whether or
not there was validity to it so for the
last 20 years or so since 911 actually
911 was the inciting incident that made
me want to investigate the religion of
my birth and get closer and um more
connected to it including you know
raising a family and so forth so uh so
that's how I practice it I learn every
day I learn I read the Bible the Old
Testament in my case um I study the
ancient philosophers I engage in weekly
study with rabbis and um and Friends uh
I keep the Sabbath I don't work um uh I
go to a temple um and so these are very
important things to me but I can't say
ultimately that I believe in God it's a
very strange thing like I don't say I
believe in gravity I never say that I
don't believe in gravity I have evidence
for gravity and so it's something so it
it really tells me that I have two sort
of fathers in a sense you know one is
one is like Galileo uh empirical uh
empirical scientist the first to come up
with the scientific method to discover
that laws of mathematics could be
verifying verifying physical phenomena
in space and he's sort of my scientific
you know um father in a sense and then I
have my you know religious father so to
speak and the people of my my ancestry
and and and so forth and philosophy But
ultimately to say that I believe in God
is a very strange thing for a scientist
so those two forces are at War Within Me
can I reconcile the two of them no can I
solve can I prove no but part of life
again a religion like I said about
science is an infinite game you can't
say I want it and when you meet with
Lawrence you can ask him the same thing
when did you stop learning about Judaism
the religion of his birth and he'll say
when he was 13 years old after he had
his bar mitzvah at the typical age not
as a 50-year old guy and uh and he
hasn't studied it since and he has a
very superficial understanding and I've
done studies with him and he will
dismiss it and I'll say it's this band
of Bronze Age peasants and what did they
know about this and that but I'll I'll
always point out that there are there
are life truths that he actually adheres
to and ow their Heritage as as much of
Western Civilization to the Old
Testament and our series of laws and so
so there's obviously wisdom and value to
it and the question is why would you
abandon a source of wisdom like I don't
read A Brief History of Time ah okay I
don't read A Brief History of Time to
know how to raise my daughter you know I
I read A Brief History of Time to learn
about a Theory of physics that's mostly
now out of favor uh that was written in
the 1980s right and that's interesting
but as you asked about like Haku before
I would have hoped and and we go back
and look at your interview with him but
when you ask him do you hope you're
right or hope you're wrong I hope that
all my theories are wrong or my ideas or
my discoveries are wrong in the same
sense as the Earth being a sphere is
wrong in other words I hope that they
get refined I hope that the ultimate
truth that we can get closer and closer
to but never exactly arrive at
is achieved after my and science
improves otherwise what's science for
well the other really important thing
about every opinion you're expressing on
the topic of whether scientists are
right or wrong and how they should feel
about it is that you have personal
experience with that and are not only
open about it you write about it in your
books because you were working on bicep
and you thought I'm not going to get
into the full terminology I will let you
do that but you thought you were looking
for one thing it turned out you were
looking at dust but you had this highly
complex potentially groundbreaking idea
that could show us what the beginning of
the cosmos might look like and then you
spend all the time on it to figure out
we don't know that and I don't think
there's anything wrong with that but in
in your field it can be that that
Scarlet Letter of oh his entire work was
was proven wrong and so when you when
you are going through all these things
and all these scientists who are afraid
to even explore the topic of well maybe
we're looking at this the wrong way you
you've been there done that I respect
that a lot about you yeah it's to me
it's it's a natural way it's not
necessarily commendable or or
condemnable but but to be open to being
wrong if you're not as you're not a
scientist and the type of of you know
flaw or or you know issue that we had
with bicep and that I describ and losing
can you explain it if you don't mind
yeah so what we were looking for again
dates back to um this this distinction
of the universe as the ultimate particle
accelerator as the ultimate Atom Smasher
particle collider however you like to
phrase it when the early Universe began
to produce out of nothing perhaps
according to lawren Crow uh Universe
from nothing a fluctuation in a quantum
foam that pre-existed our current
universe and what's called the
Multiverse um perhaps or the collapse of
a previous Universe onto itself that
ignites an explosive origin event that
then became the universe that we know
and love
today that event whatever it was may
have been accompanied by a new type of
force field called inflation so a
totally different only existed for a
vanishingly small amount of time for
actually a trillionth of a trillionth of
a trillionth of a second 10 Theus 36
seconds this phenomenon called inflation
took place where the universe expanded
from atom size to the size of over uh
the of a of a school bus that's based on
time as we know it in this Dimension
though right it would it would be aapse
time as we say it you know in other
words you had a stopwatch I could
measure trillionth of seconds you'd see
a trillionth of a trillionth of a
trillionth of a second go by yeah so
absolutely the correct correct way to
think about it so the universe expanded
from you know less than the size of a
you know kind of atomic size or molecule
size to the size of a school bus in a TR
so faster than the speed of light and
that that um that conjecture
then if true explains a host of other
Cosmic phenomena including the um the
the structure of galaxies that we see in
the universe the clusters of galaxies
that we see in the universe the um uh
and and many other phenomena it's called
inflation it's sort of the spark if you
think about the Big Bang as an explosion
it's not really an explosion of any kind
like a firecracker but if you want to
think about it fine it would be the
match that Lit it off and that match was
only ignited for a trillionth of a
trillionth of a trillionth of a second
okay so that be that event then cast the
die for what our universe would look
like so by looking at the universe today
we can infer what properties it would
have had in the past just like we can
infer that you from the way you look
that you were once an egg and a sperm we
don't know exactly which egg and which
sperm you know I'm going to keep a PG
here I know you're classy right it's a
very RR podcast so you're okay okay as
you want um so you can even like
nucleate you know when the first that
first single uh cell became two two
different different cells and start to
split um and start to divide it's called
a Blas assy it's a collection of cells
um we can infer what that looked like
even though we don't know what you would
look like so in other words we're
looking at you today and I'm trying to
predict what was that blast assist that
that 100 cell Clump that you were 100
seconds after your parents big bang you
know whatever 30 years ago right exactly
so when that happened we can make
inferences about that in the same way we
can observe the shrapnel from the
universe the properties of the universe
today and infer what was it like at this
early
but we've only been able to go back to
about 380,000 years after the big bang
to this time using light light is
produced in the form of the cosmic
microwave background discovered here in
juny uh down the road in home sorry uh
so they G get all these people think I'm
a white nationalist uh but anyway uh
they'll have to read my autobiography to
know about it um I'm not but uh but
anyway looking back at the uh at the
heat that's left over that's as far back
as you can go with light but you know if
there's a i rate you know cabbie driving
across the street here we can't see him
but we could hear another form of
radiation I.E sound right if he HS F you
or whatever right or uh you know go
Giants uh you could hear it so other
forms of radiation can tell you about
things that are not only um of a
different type of phenomena but actually
are farther away and remember I said
when something's farther away it's older
in time you're seeing it as it was young
so we're using instead of waves of sound
a type of vibration called the
gravitational wave so if inflation took
place which we don't know we're trying
to substantiate find evidence for but we
not trying to prove it remember that's
not our goal we're not trying to prove
it we're trying to falsify everything
else all other competing theories do not
have these waves of gravity only
inflation does so therefore if we see
inflation we don't prove sorry if we see
gravitational waves in a background they
emanated from this trillionth of a
trillionth of a trillionth of a second
after the origin of our of our
observable universe potentially from
another Multiverse a larger expans of
SpaceTime and that falsifies all these
other models static Universe bouncing
model cyclical cosmology uh string gas
cosmology all these there are many many
models that don't feature this type of
behavior it instantly be proven wrong we
thought we did that on March 17 2014 we
announced that we had done that with a
previous experiment uh a successor to an
experiment I invented called bicep this
one was called bicep 2 very creatively
it was announced at uh at Harvard Avi
lobe was part of the announcement where
were you doing this uh so this
experiment was done at the South Pole
Antarctica it was a telescope just like
Galileo has made a refracting telescope
and used it to learn about the origins
of the of his own Universe for all the
flat earther you walked off the edge
that's right I went to the bottom and
you know like I saw I saw with my own
eyes how actually if you're there it
looks totally flat it's it's pretty
funny the South Pole it'ss just like you
know the most flat boring you know even
even worse than the central P Pine
Barons here but anyway looking at the uh
looking at the early Universe from this
vantage point we claim we saw these
waves of gravity via their imprint on
What's called the cosmic mic background
and yet and yet we knew there other
impostor signals no scientist nowadays
go what do you mean by impostor signal a
signal that could produce the exact same
effect mimicking inflationary
gravitational waves but but not produced
by gravitational wngs it would be like
you saw you look through a telescope and
your theory is that the moon has this
swirling fingerprint on it there's a
pattern of of craters and valleys and
volcanoes on the moon surface okay and
your theory is that there canals on the
moon and they're shaped and they're made
by a God and the god left his
fingerprint on the moon okay so you're
looking through your telescope I saw
evidence for that holy crap I'm going to
be super F then you look at the
telescope oh shoot I put my thumb on the
on the lens okay so we we saw something
that exactly mimicked the signal that we
were looking for which was inflation
this swirling twisting pattern of
microwaves called B mode polarization I
describe in the book in great detail and
that pattern was produced not by the
waves of gravity just like in this
analogy not by canals on the on the moon
or or um or you know swirling pattern by
a God no it was produced by tiny little
microm meteorites passing that micro
meteor I gave you so generously Billy
right here this uh Billy boy for Billy
boy so if you put this in space remember
I said this is what what is this made of
Pop Quiz what's the most of it what's in
your blood iron iron yeah so iron is the
predominant uh makes up the predominant
composition of this meteorite little of
nickel Cobalt and some other elements
okay what number on the table is that
what say that again iron iron is 27 you
got a computer here so I think it's
you're the scientist 27 all right just
don't memorize all these things right I
I leave that Li chist they said you got
to memorize all this [__] I would not
advise that at all I'm guessing it's
27 or so element periodic table y let's
see it let's see what we got here let's
see it baby 26 you're one off W that
tough dang it anyway um so when this is
in space this or if it's in your
refrigerator or if you win one from
g.com you put a refrigerator magnet on
it it will stick to it cuz it's magnet
magnetic iron is highly it's Compass
needles and can be made of it so it gets
aligned by magnetic fields just like the
needle of a compass so this is like an
odd shape for a magnetic needle for a
compass but it actually can act like a
magnetic compass imagine this shrunk
down or shaved off if I were cheaper I
would have brought you like a little
tiny shaving of it like a little filing
a little tiny particle of it well
there's a lot of those you ever heard of
a power law power law is something that
there's a lot of things that are small
and there's very few things like
companies there are a lot of small
companies pizza restaurants you know uh
you know gift shops or whatever and
there's very few like apples I you know
and Google talk like zero to one
Concepts Z to one yeah that's a power L
exactly so there's there can be you know
10 times as many that are 10 times
smaller there's actually thousands and
millions of times more that are the
fraction of a of a of a of a width of a
human hair but they're all in space too
from the same Supernova that blew up in
our G in our local corner of the Galaxy
5 billion years ago or so those are
still in our galaxy and there's many of
these Supernova throughout our galaxy
there's about one every hundred years so
the Milky Way is over 5 billion years
old six seven billion years old so
there's been many times for these
Hundred Year periods to produce a
supernova to blow up yes so this uh
particular um uh phenomena then can can
uh these little grains of iron can get
aligned but there's a magnetic field in
almost every object in the universe you
know the Earth has a magnetic field uh
we our bodies have a slight magnetic
field the Galaxy the solar system has
magnetic field and that can align these
tiny little microscopic grains of dust
made of meteoric material in space and
actually produce the same pattern and
Mock and mimic it exactly what we were
looking for and that's what we saw we
saw dust grains in our galaxy so it
wasn't like a thumb print you know we
didn't leave the lens cap on you know
the thumbnail it wasn't stupid it was it
wasn't a blunder yeah it was an
astrophysical phenomena and it just
wasn't a cosmological phenomena how did
you figured that out so we worked with
our critics this is this Hallmark of
good scientists that there was another
experiment that were our Arch
competitors or Nemesis called Plank and
plank was a billion Euro experiment
launched into space with parts built by
my late adviser Andrew Lang and Jamie
boach and other people that were members
of the bicep team uh and they had done
this mainly LED out of the European
Space Agency George aadu and many other
great scientists worked on it for many
many years launched into deep orbit four
times the distance to the Earth Earth to
the Moon beyond the orbit of the moon
and they launched this telescope and
they had data that we lacked and the
data that they had that we lacked was
exceptionally accessible and exquisitely
sensitive to dust not to the cosmic
signal as much as we were but to the
dust signal so what we saw and Stephen
Hawking used say every equation Cuts
your readership by half so I won't do
any other podcast equations I don't want
to cut the listenership by more than
half but I have to do this what we were
seeing was the Comm
imagine the signal s that we saw was the
cosmic signal C plus dust D okay so s
equals c it's actually not that
complicated plus d okay but now it's
going to get complicated because we have
to invoke subtraction additions tricky
pal so then we had from the plank our
competitors trying to see the same thing
trying to win the same number of prizes
as us they could measure the dust signal
so then we took their data in
combination with us they originally
wouldn't give it to us they would have
helped if they gave it to us you know 6
months earlier we wouldn't have put out
this you know publication that led to
this press conference that led to us
being on the front page of the New York
Times um and other things and then we
wouldn't have had to retract it of
course I wouldn't have written my book
but that's the way life goes life works
out okay um so they measured the D
signal we combine it with C plus d or we
subtracted it from C plus d and what's
left is C in other words two you needed
another experiment what was that like in
the analogy when I said you put your
thumb on the on the lens that means that
somebody else did another experiment
your competitor said hey
hey Julian look there there's a thumb
print on your lens that's technically
it's another experiment oh okay let me
wipe it off now I remove the dust signal
or the fingerprint signal and what's
left is the pure signal and that and
that didn't have any evidence for the
gravitational waves which would have
meant inflation took place which would
have meant that we live in a Multiverse
so now it's not that would have meant we
lived in a Multiverse it's almost
impossible to have inflationary
gravitational waves present if the
Multiverse is also not similarly true
why is that
so this is aine Multiverse for the
people out there who aren't familiar so
cernus and Galileo and others came up
with the idea that the Earth is not
special the Earth is just one planet
it's not even the center of our solar
system the sun is the center of our
solar system later astronomers came up
with the idea that the uh solar system
is not the center of the Galaxy later
people came up with this the notion that
our galaxy is just one of other galaxies
and it is not in the center of the
universe and the natural extension of
this capern reasoning is that we are not
the only Universe in a greater vaster
Cosmos called the Multiverse the
Multiverse is depending on who you get
to Define it there's multiple
multiverses to make things super
confusing a multiverses or
multivers I I'm so bothered by this
there so many talk to my friend Andrew
huberman he'll say it's octopuses not
octopi oct the [__] again wait a
second here hold on
heyo Howard dor show
uh so when you look at the um the
progression it's not out of the question
that there could be other universes that
we don't have access to just like if we
go out into the Atlantic Ocean go off
Long Island and we go fishing we can't
see land but we could hear let's say you
know there's a firework show or or
somebody drops you know something or
boat crashes you know in the harbor we
can see the waves coming from it over
the horizon that gives us information
about what kind of boats they were how
fast were they traveling how an angle
did they hit each other on again it look
for the Flat Earth exactly they're just
taking a lot of Ls
today so when we look back at into uh
into the history of cosmology what we
see is that the only way that you could
get inflation to Spring forth from
nothing literally a universe from
nothing would mean that there are other
potential universes that could exist and
that we could someday obtain evidence
for and in that sense I think it's
interesting to note that if we don't get
evidence for it it's not proof that the
Multiverse doesn't exist it's it's not
proof that the UN that the Universe
didn't begin with inflation it's merely
a statement again what are trying to do
is prove things wrong not prove things
right so you can't prove the Multiverse
is true you can only prove that a theory
that doesn't have say gravitational
waves is false by observing
gravitational waves if you had proved
that there was a reasonably High
expectation based on the data that the
Multiverse system existed would you have
at the same time been able to say
therefore it is it is possible to to
and probably has been done before to
transverse or Traverse time so not
necessarily no they're not necessarily
related to each other um so it could be
that there are there other remember
there's different types of of uh when I
say there's a Multiverse it really
there's not just one type of Multiverse
there's a Multiverse in quantum
mechanics it's called the many worlds
interpretation popularized by a
physicist at Princeton of course as many
great things came out of New Jersey lot
of good stuff in Jersey I know this is
where Einstein was too don't forget that
Einstein John Archer bald wheeler was
here Fineman was here great state man
yeah I'm going to sell you on it I I I
SP I spent a summer in Spring Lake I
enjoyed it Asbury Park yeah Point
Pleasant Point pleas absolutely lot of
good bars there a lot well I was too
were you a fighter back then what's that
were you a fighter no was Brian bar
fighter that's right no it was not as
was a nine-year-old um they love
throwing hands just with my brothers
yeah uh so when I uh
yeah so so it's basically a a concept
that in quantum mechanics you've heard
of shinger cat yes there's a notion that
oh yeah right so the notion the cat uh
in quantum mechanics can be represented
as a superposition of two different
completely orthogonal states that are
only revealed once an observer makes a
measurement I should have said this a
lot more times today but in English now
okay right well I can do it in Hebrew if
you like I can let's start English work
our way to Hebrew um so uh what there is
in a famous Paradox called Schrodinger's
cat quantum mechanics is a description
of the most uh tiniest abstract element
building blocks of nature called
particles and these particles the most
common ones that we deal with are
electrons as I said and and subatomic
particles like quarks but the classic
one is an electron electrons only have
these three properties charge mass and
spin um and they're described not by the
laws of Isaac Newton that describes you
know Force equals mass time acceler
ation how things fall gravity and stuff
they're described by an analogous
equation called the shary equation the
shary equation predicts in some sense
the probability that you'll find an
electron at a given point in space at a
given time uh in uh that the measurement
is done but the key is that these
objects evolve that the the state of the
electron behaves sort of like a wave
where there's an oscillating probability
to find it at this state in a given
place at a given time and that it only
depends on the interaction between the
thing that you're uh the thing you're
describing the electron and something
has to observe it and when you observe
it you soall collapse the wave function
and what's called The Copenhagen
interpretation of quantum mechanic
unlike classical we don't have an
interpretation of classical mechanic you
don't say well in Newton's Laws of of uh
of acceleration force equals masstimes
acceleration but in King Kaku Theory it
goes like you know Mass equals this cube
root whatever it we don't have to
interpret it like what is the meaning of
position no we know what it is but when
something's like spread out and diffuse
and is only probabilistic then you have
to ask well like does this thing exist
when I don't look at it Einstein used to
ask like does the moon exist if you
don't look at it so there's an interplay
that you don't have because in classical
physics I can do I can look at this
object moving through space and I can
plot it you know just from the camera
there it's moving as I drop it and then
I can construct did that fall at 9.8 m/s
squared under the force of gravity did
his velocity inre increase 9.8 m in the
first
second um and you will obtain that just
from looking at that what's happening
when the camera does this measurement
there's lights in the room yes the
lights are bouncing off of here and
going into the camera and the sensor and
the camera and there's a Time clock and
the camera's built in and you can see
how many frames it took to fall and you
can measure it really accurately what if
I reduce this down to the size of an
electron okay let's do the same
experiment let's drop it it should in
abstract sense fall at the exact same
rate 9.8 meters per second but wait it's
not a point it's not a even a
well-defined boundary or border like
this meteorite has there's a fuzzy
probabilistic Cloud that's one problem
here's another problem when the lights
from the uh from the overhead lighting
rig the very expensive and incredibly
beautiful lighting rig here in the
studio um when they bounce off the
electron that changes the path of the
electron because they're they have a lot
of energy and momentum compared to the
size of the thing you're talking about
unlike this thing this thing don't
change that at all like not even one
micro No in fact there's probably equal
pressure from other the vast amount of
other photons that are also hitting it
from other directions so the art and
then you could say well what if I don't
look at it well that could not affect
its properties no you the best you can
say is there's a probability for it to
behave just like it's a a brick falling
or a meteorite falling through space and
so what there is in quantum mechanics is
this interpretation you have to say well
when I look at it what happens to its
position and momentum here's another way
to think about it imagine you're in a
room and it's completely dark and we put
on this table here a pingpong ball and I
tell you it's moving around and I ask
you Julian tell me exactly what its
velocity is and tell me exactly where it
is how would you do that just with your
hands oh here's the pingpong ball it's
rolling around in here I would do it by
pointing but you wouldn't see me
hypothetically it's totally dark it's
totally dark yep so how would you do
it I might use like sound to be able to
show you it's rolling from here to there
okay something like that let's say you
do it with sound you know echolocation
is what it's called another way you
could do it is let's say close your eyes
it's moving around and you put your
hands around it you keep making your
hand smaller and then finally you
measure it right so now I measured it I
know exactly where it is but what do I
know about its velocity I don't know
anything well that's what I was saying
okay but even with that you're hitting
it with sound wav choc so the lighter
and the smaller and the less mass of
these particles get the the more you
disturb it by doing a measurement so
what Schrodinger's cat um kind of
attempts to say is that in one
interpretation the cat could physically
be represented as a living cat and a
dead cat and the the cat dies by the way
of when you um every so often there's a
radioactive beta Decay nuclear Decay
that shoots and gets detected by a guer
counter here's a click it it breaks open
a capsule of Cyanide and that kills the
cat the question is what do the cat
State before you open it up there
because the the decay of radioactive
nuclei is purely quantum mechanical
there's some way it's like the electron
but the cats living or dead is a
classical phenomenon all the molecules
of the cat are dead or alive in this
scenario so when you open the box you
look at it you determine you collapse
the way function and you force the cat
to either be alive or dead so in that's
in the Copenhagen interpretation and
what's called the many worlds
interpretation the cat in one Universe
goes and is off in the living state for
all time you never collapsed it and
never changed and never was dead at any
time or super position it doesn't have
to be in a super position and in the
other one it goes into a state where
it's dead and that's in Another Universe
it's dead in that so there's a
Multiverse of quantum mechanics as well
as a Multiverse of
cosmology and um uh and yes it's more
complicated than all the Marvel movies
written with the word verse or
Multiverse or spiderverse yeah it's very
complicated but it's very interesting
and again the reason that these Stakes
are so high is that because if we had
observed these waves of gravity if we
had been verified or if my future
experiment the Simon Observatory does
observe these conclusively again it
doesn't prove but it gives Credence to
inflation and inflation comes as a big
word conomon always comes associated
with the
Multiverse in other words it's almost
impossible to have and you can talk to
Lawrence about this when he's here it's
almost impossible to have inflation
without having the
Multiverse so therefore the stakes get
even higher right on one hand we would
have detected gravitational waves for
the first time in this way that one and
prize two years three years afterwards
what's called ligo um and then it would
have been a detection of inflation which
is the spark the match that ignited the
Big Bang that's like a second big bang
second Nobel Prize and then it would
have been indirect evidence as I say for
the multivers which you know who knows
how many Nobel prizes that would have
been worth how many years of research
from the first time someone one of you
guys thought about it in a room to the
moment you guys figured out it was wrong
went into bicep uh 15 years probably $8
million and many trips to the South Pole
and and many people's career but again
it wasn't wrong and actually it is the
best experiment still of its kind ever
done even better than my current
experiment which is the Simon's
Observatory it wasn't wrong you just
weren't able to observe what you were
testing we observed exquisitly measured
the properties of of dust in our in our
galaxy so in that sense we had claimed
was we had observed the the ignition of
the Big Bang the inflationary Epoch do
you believe that that's still exists and
is out there but you guys just didn't
have the ability to see it again I don't
believe in things right we as ask what
we have evidence for and so we don't
have evidence for it yet we have
circumstantial evidence that's very
strong that's suggestive of the fact or
else we wouldn't be building the
experiment that the best you know the uh
the explanation that seems to explain
the most disperate phenomena is
inflation but this will be the Smoking
Gun in other words you come to the scene
of a crime and you're like there's a
dead body how did he die you don't know
but if you see there's a gun and there's
smoke coming out of it these waves of
gravity are like the smoke from that gun
mhm and so if we do see it again it's
not it doesn't prove it right he could
have also been poisoned and then shot
you know whatever I don't know what you
guys do here in New Jersey but uh we're
not going to get into the mafia or
anything like that um we have our own
Mafia uh cosmology so um so yeah I think
it's it's uh it's but it be strong and
circumstantial evidence is is evidence
right you can't dismiss it um but but
you can't also say it's it proves once
and for all but for for most people this
is the Holy Grail for the type of
cosmology that we're doing which is why
uh you know these these agencies have
put 100 million dollars into building
this instrument in Chile which is now
the focus of my career and probably will
be for the remainder of it what was that
moment like when you realized you were
observing dust and how quickly did it
happen that's a great question um it it
was always a question in the back of my
mind and and all of our minds I mean
they're all great scientists um I had
been sort of removed from the leadership
of the experiment after the suicide of
the the the principal investigator of it
it was my mentor Andrew Lang oh he
committed suicide yeah yeah so Sor to
hear that yeah so he he committed
suicide only a few weeks after we had
gotten the the the instrument working at
the South Pole and and it was a just a
tremendous but he was like a you know
Father Figure career-wise to me and he
would also you know he was a very good
personal friend of mine and you know I
was very devastated by Left Behind three
kids and and just haul in millions of
people I mean he was like the
quintessential like uber scientist I
would say like look remember that guy
like Mad Men what's his name John Ham
he's like just Don Draper yeah Don
Draper yeah he's like right behind you
super pictures right there oh yeah there
he is right so he was um he was just
like handsome and Brilliant and Surefire
he was going to win a Nobel Prize his
his widow ended up winning the Nobel
Prize in chemistry a few years ago after
he died wow um different different they
weren't working together but there's
power couple you know beautiful people
beautiful family and nobody
nobody expected it I think and uh it's
just completely devastating to anybody
that knew him uh and uh you know cast a
PA over the whole project in a certain
sense but by the time we had gotten
enough data to say once and for all that
we had detected this pattern and
ultimately we did detect the pattern and
the pattern is more significant than
ever and we know it more accurately and
more precisely than ever we just know
that it's not necessarily from the
cosmos but rather from our galaxy which
is interesting but it's not significant
in the sense of you know understanding
How the Universe began so we're still
they are still I'm not affiliated with
that experiment anymore but it's gone
from bicep one that I co-invented all
the way up in 2000 you asked me how long
it was we started in
2000 2001 and we built and this
announcement was in 2014 so that you
know 14 13 years uh and then the
retraction came sort of six months later
we didn't retract it we said we we
rescinded the interpretation that it
came from the origin of the universe and
we said the most likely explanation is
that it came from dust and the only way
we could do that is by working with our
former competitors on this plank billion
Euro satellite that was launched a few
years before you know we made these
announcements was there any sort of I
mean you had called them like you use
competitors there but you had called
them critics earlier was there any sort
of like intense behind the scenes drag
it out arguments after this came out or
or was it more you guys were
all just looking for the truth and one
to team up and do it I mean I've been
kind of surprised how little blowback
we've gotten or the leadership again I
wasn't in the I didn't make the decision
to have a press conference and you know
go to the New York Times and and so
forth I was I had been even though I had
started the predecessor experiment and I
was still involved with it and my
students were still working on bicep 2
um so those decisions and so forth were
made under the threat of pressure that
we would be scooped in this discovery by
this plank satellite which had claimed
that they were going to beat us and they
had all the budget and a much bigger
team than we did and they were in space
which is for technical reasons much
better than being even at the South Pole
which is a great location for doing this
type of
work so um the critics um are came in a
variety of forms so we we published this
paper um online it wasn't peer-reviewed
when we made the press conference that's
how nervous the leadership was about
getting scooped by Plank and that they
wouldn't share their data with us before
release also probably gave them some
concern that they were about to get
scooped so we they went ahead and
published it and it was actually not
peer-reviewed for many months afterwards
and then a few months after it was peer
reviewed accepted and published then it
was basically retracted uh by working
with these um with the former
competitors so but there were other
critics that were you know basically
saying that we had made these flaws and
made basically blunders not not not
astrophysically wrong that we had
basically done bad scientific research
that we were wrong and not good
scientifically thumb on the camera uh
yeah basically that we just totally
overlooked the most basic you know Astro
101 you know flum uh you know flubs and
and bloopers and they were totally they
were just critics and I would say they
don't count and so that's the critic in
the you know that's not in the arena
right but you know it's better to own
the telescope and own the arena than
than to sit on the sidelines you know
throwing uh throwing rocks of dust you
yeah and and what are you had hinted at
it a few minutes ago but what are you
working on now
so once you realize that the signal is
going to be accompanied by this impostor
that can mimic the signal that you're
looking for you know it's kind of like
fool me once shame on you fool me twice
shame on me so now we're aware of it
we're on notice so every experiment
that's looking for the inflationary
gravitational wave background the signal
that could be the harbinger that
inflation took place to ignite the big
bang into propelling the universe to
expand for basically the foreseeable
future and that comes as I say conomon
big word but it it's very descriptive
with the Multiverse that you basically
cannot have the inflationary
gravitational waves without the
Multiverse um now all hands are on Deck
so now we have embedded in our team
people who only focus on dust and in
their team too on the bicep team which
is now called bicep array the fourth
generation of the bicep program so they
have people that really just focus on
modeling understanding dust
understanding the magnetic field of the
Galaxy are there other experiments from
LX optical telescope so the same dust
that that emits these microwaves that
confused us also obstructs and blocks
the light from Stars Behind the clouds
of dust in our Milky Way galaxy so we're
working with Optical astronomers we're
working with people that look at the
magnetic field of the Galaxy because
that's what aligns the dust and we're
looking at people that build radio
telescopes at very high frequencies and
very low frequencies in order to get
more information only about dust and
contaminants so now what bicep couldn't
do bicep array and the Simon Observatory
are now doing both with um collaborators
external to the project in other words
different teams using optical telescopes
which have nothing to do with what we're
doing um uh looking at staright
polarization and the light of stars um
and people on our own team that are
building channels and and aspects of our
experiment that can only see dust so we
have internal uh calibration tools and
external calibration tools and those are
all to remove the systematic thumb print
on the l so to speak wow yeah so it it's
amazing how long this stuff takes I mean
people spend their whole like like we've
been saying people will spend their
whole life working on one thing but
that's what makes it so exciting you
know and that's why I think I like you
know to study the both the biggest
picture things in science which you know
this type of science that I get to do
unifies the physics of the very small
with the physics of the largest thing IM
imaginable the Multiverse it even has
implications for the existence of life
in the universe for Consciousness and
for observe the wave function of the
universe is there a conscious Observer
now you start to dovetail into
theological consideration I mean to me
it's like I'm a kid in the intellectual
candy store so I I never get enough of
it I never want to retire it's so much
fun yeah it's it's it's so like these
are the kinds of things that when I was
a kid if it didn't if it wasn't bouncing
a basketball or throwing around a
football like I didn't care that much
you know like I look at physics now now
I just wasn't interested in it when I
did it and then when I got into my 20s
I'm like oh my God this is so [__]
cool don't make the mistake Julie don't
make that mistake go to relativistic
astrophysics graduate school before you
start a podcast go do math and science
before you start a podcast I'll indorse
that doc I'm a doctor nine out of 10
doctors agree with that it's it's it's
really like when you think about the
patterns of the world and and you were
reminding me of this earlier when you
were talking about that object in your
hand there and about how there is I'm
going to get this wrong how I say it but
there's basically like more massive
things that happen at the top and then
it trickles down and opens up at the
bottom and then you think about like our
parallels as to how the world Works
Among Us 8 billion humans and you have
the people who are rich at the top all
the way spreading out to the people who
are po at the bottom these these things
right these exactly these numbers and
and these these patterns of how things
are are distributed around the mean they
exist universally and they exist here
just in our little [__] behaviors
together as humans yeah I you see you
start to see connections and that's part
of the job of a scientist is to notice
anomalies patterns things that don't fit
in seek them out try to explain them
with existing understanding technology
tools and data and then where not
possible extend by making new laws new
ideas new
hypothesis and I think that that's
healthy sign of what makes humans unique
is that we have that capability to do
you know with our frontal cortex to
think about experiments that aren't yet
done you know like most chimpanzees are
not doing like thought experiments like
if I drop an apple on top of this
beehive you know um it'll hit at the
Beehive with the same amount of speed as
a hitting it with a giant rock but I
should hit with you know they're not
doing these thought experiments we are
um and and just the capacity that we
have to imagine
scenarios is is just you know quite
frankly something that we should all
have a little bit of cosmic Swagger over
but I always say you know there's a
quote from the telet that you should
have two pockets and in your pockets you
should have two pieces of paper one that
says the whole universe was made for me
that's the swagger like it's my
playground it's my delight it's my
garden of heavenly paradise and I can
find things that give me Beauty and I
say like we could be like bacteria in a
in a Petri dish right bacteria are
eating agar have you ever tasted agine
think yeah uh picture like the worst
possible you know gelatinous you know
non-flavored it's just purely to get
them to grow and make colonies and and
and so that scientists can study them
that could be what every you know like
instead of delicious coffee and the
mixture with the cream and then you know
just incredible flavors and then the
visual Sensation that we have we have a
spectrum on our tongue and we can taste
these different things and we can see
different colors and people and interact
with them in a network and that gives us
happiness so the whole world was made
for our pleasure in that sense on the
other hand you should have another
pocket with a piece of paper says we are
nothing but dust basically our future is
dust we came from dust we're nothing
we're cosmically insignificant and um D
to dust yeah and how do you balance that
how do you balance the humility with the
Swagger because you can't do good
science if you're only uh just purely
you know humiliated humbled and and just
have this this this fear of like well
what is a person I can't do anything and
similarly you can't um you can't really
expect to proceed flawlessly if you
always think I got this ctal Swagger I'm
the man you know I know everything
because we know almost nothing so
balancing those two is a job of a
scientist and I think you know besides
getting up in you know stupid culture
wars and political partisan fighting uh
it's what makes life so exciting and
interesting to be a scientist that
little thre liner story you had about
you just remind me of it about Albert
Einstein testing people with IQ I think
I've told that to like 40 people since I
heard that that's one of the best things
ever yeah my my father used to say that
to me where basically like someone walks
in says to Einstein I want to talk about
science he goes great what's your IQ he
says 140 he goes awesome we can talk
about String Theory this this or that
second guy walks in says oh I want to
talk about science Einstein says great
what's your IQ he says 130 he goes
awesome we could talk about relativity
this this and that third guy walks in
says I want to talk about science and
Einstein says great what's your IQ and
he says 100 and he goes all right we'll
talk about the [__] culture War
that is man does that explain Society in
so many ways because I know some of it
like you know you have to get to we're
talking obviously a little bit outside
the scientific realm right now but you
know you have to get to some consensus
on how to play nice and the sandbox
together I understand that but we spend
so much time bullshitting and fighting
over you know who tucks their sack back
or not and it just gets so exhausting
and I don't care you know I find I can
imagine guys like you in your field who
are busy trying to figure out the most
important questions of the world you
know turn on the TV and hear what these
two [__] are fighting about for any
given five minute sound bite and you're
just like what what am I even doing here
these people are the same species as me
it's crazy yeah it's it's frustrating
and I think you know the only thing the
only person you can control is yourself
and most of us can't even do that very
well and I think you know to dedicate
your time in the right way in the proper
way and just concentrate forever with
meditative you know Sam Harris like
ability is is is beyond most people but
I think you know to the extent that you
can synthesize and harmonize your what
you do for work and that you can get
meaning out of what you do and also
significance about what you do I think
that's really powerful I don't think
that I would have you know I I wrote my
book long before I had a podcast um but
at the same token I think I get a lot
more satisfaction out of those types of
things because you know for the mere
fact that you could spread education you
know my job education it's interesting
the word education means to pour out of
I'll demonstrate here no we would never
spill any liquids on this table did
that so it means to pour out of not to
pour into most people think oh I'm going
to jam all this educate knowledge is the
street SMS you got Street SMS you don't
have any book SMS you know so pouring it
in no you're actually bringing out of
but now who is know who was born knowing
you know uh knowing uh abstract algebra
and you know relativity and group Theory
you know nobody very you know so you
have to be mindful that you have this
opportunity to do it but you're also not
expected to understand all of it uh nor
are you expected to desist from it so
for me I often talk to my colleagues and
I'm like why don't you put out a YouTube
video you know why don't you do
something why don't you besides this
paper that was read by six people all of
whom are your friends or your former
students or whatever not everyone's as
good on camera as Brian ke but you but
that's not the point I I wasn't always
good at on the camera either you know
when my first book came out I had all my
editor at Norton and they were like oh
you should start a channel and start be
an explainer and you could be the next
Neil degrass Tyson and and do all this
and you know he was published by the
same Publishing House Norton and uh I
was like I don't have time for that I'm
a real scientist I got to work I got to
put out these papers I got to advise
graduates and I still do all that but
I've come to see that it's my moral
obligation you know that I get paid to
do this job and it's because of the
taxpayers that I get to do it and every
scientist is the same way and when you
hear somebody say that and you and you
hear them say well I'm not good at it
and I always say oh yeah yeah I forgot
when you were born you understood
Quantum electrodynamics and you
understood String Theory no no no I had
to I had to work on that oh oh I see you
work on things that are meaningful to
you and matter to you oh I see oh so you
just saying that's for people like Neil
degrass Tyson who most scientists don't
have a lot of respect for oh he's just a
popular because they're just like he's
just well he's not a SC he's not a
active SCI he's not advising you know
writing papers and doing research any
anymore he was has a PHD and he was
trained in it but even he will say he's
not an active scientist and to give him
his credit you know a lot of people
don't I just saw him on Bill Maher and
Bill M was like going off on him for
being you know less than forceful in
regards to college campuses um but uh
this funny Bill m going off on him but
um but Neil uh Neil will say you know if
you come and ask me about what's the
latest development string theory and um
you know and whatnot he'll say you know
go talk to Brian green or you know some
an active scientist not not me who's
doing Star Talk and popularization so I
have respect for people like that um but
to say that you can only do that only do
Outreach and do a podcast or make a
video or Tik Tok or whatever if you're
Neil degrass Tyson who I don't respect
because he's not a real scientist is
what people say not me then go do it
your damn self right so that's that's
true and just but but by the same token
what if they would say well I'm not
Einstein so I'm not GNA even start doing
F Einstein wasn't always Einstein you
know he wasn't always oh the god
equation you know Kaku wasn't always
Kaku and Weinstein wasn't always
Weinstein right so from this perspective
if you start off with this only again
the humility has to be balanced with the
Swagger I have the same number of
chromosomes I have the same number of
muscles and body you know uh that
doesn't mean I'm G to be Joe Rogan in
the ring or as a podcaster but if I say
I'm not going to do because I can't be
the best at it I'm not going to do it or
because it's hard for me that's the joke
to me it's like yeah well so is like you
know going on a diet or so is you know
teaching your your uh you know
5-year-old to ride a bike these are not
easy things and humans have to be
generalists we have to know a lot about
many different things we're not insects
hinin said you know we're insects are
for specializations for insects not for
human beings so you should be able to
change a diaper write a novel fight in a
war and you in my case look through a
telescope yeah I've never really bought
the the argument about not being able to
to teach it and and that whole rivalry
that happens because you know someone
has to get kids in this country
interested in this stuff again too you
got to get them dreaming and asking the
questions we used to ask when we were
young like what are the stars what's
going on in the sky you know and and
also what built a lot of this country I
mean we just had a movie come out over
the summer Oppenheimer about the guys
who in who invented the nuke during
World War II which effectively ended
that thing I mean physicists and science
are at the middle of everything that
happens and so you know I've heard that
criticism like a lot with
Kaku but like a guy like that forget
Tyson for one second but like Kaku spent
years doing science and now say for the
last two decades he's focused very hard
on being as he describes himself a
popularizer of the subject and what I
like about him is he makes he he will
take a lot of complex things and make it
simple he will make it fun he'll tell a
story with it you know he he knows very
well how to explain some of his stuff
and he'll do it a 100 times over so that
people a kid can be like oh that makes
sense you know what I mean and so we
have to celebrate that we should be
celebrating both in my opinion we should
be celebrating the people who are trying
to break those Frontiers right now which
is not necessarily something he's
actively trying to do anymore and we
should celebrate the people who are
getting kids to go wow this is cool I
enjoy that yeah but of course the
subtext that again I'm going to push
back with my rugged good looks and
handsome criticism but I always
criticize with love um but I actually
think that's that's kind of um you know
they call the benign bigot tree of low
expectations like if you say well you
stay in your lane which is you know
distillation of what you're saying um I
think it does some damage not only
because you would have I mean you
wouldn't tell like imagine you me some
cool smart young you know girl and she's
into YouTube and she's really into
YouTube but she wants to be a physicist
you want say well like just keep doing
the YouTube thing and and don't go to
graduate school or don't go right so you
wouldn't tell her to stick in in her
Lane so I guess the the but but also for
my students are you know many of them
I've had 40 different students from
foreign countries and all around the
world every continent including
Antarctica really had students on yeah
from Antarctica well they weren't born
there but they lived there for many many
months yeah where do you even live
that's where uh that's where we live so
I described it in my book losing the
Nobel PR interesting so yeah one of my
students lived six months at the South
Pole basically he almost became a
permanent citizen six months I mean okay
you think you think Hoboken is exciting
go to the South Pole BBE um so but but
these students they get uh exposure to
another dimension of their Persona their
um their ability to communicate if you
can't explain it to you know as the the
stereotypical grandmother then you don't
really understand it you may understand
it but you may feature what Pinker calls
the curse of knowledge where you're just
so a your Di and so brilliant uh you
can't understand what it's like not to
know something like that
you may get so siloed and you just talk
in the Echo chamber of Academia that you
don't know how to relate to a common
person I would say like imagine you came
up you know you're hired um you know a
producer for the show and you say I want
you to do X Y and Z and then uh maybe
they do it and maybe they don't but
whenever you ask them what they do they
say oh you can't understand what I'm
doing Julian you think you can
understand with the magic that I am I'm
so specialized these tools and
techniques and and behaviors that I have
manifest you'd be like you know I'll go
and get another producer like you're
going to treat me that's a HSPA you know
that is not acceptable and yet we let
scientists do that basically saying like
if it was you know as Fineman used to
say you know if it was uh easy to
explain to you it wouldn't be worth a
Nobel Prize no I think you really don't
but he would also say if you don't
explain it to your grandmother you don't
understand it so um we have to balance
that but we Short change our our
students by not forcing them to I had
this you know online argument I guess
with the this guy Brett Hall or Brent
Hall I think Brett Brett or Brent anyway
he wrote he does all these podcasts with
nval Rob account and they their BFFs I
guess and he was oh no like it's the
opposite of what you did you know like
you became good at at podcasting and
then after you were a scientist now
you're telling people not to do that I'm
like what are you talking about all I'm
saying is it's good for your students to
get exposure to public speaking one of
the things I do for my students that
come from foreign countries I pay for
them out of my own pocket to go to Toast
Masters you know like they just what are
they going to you know like they came
from Thailand or China and they're now
learning to speak and maybe their accent
is still going to be just as strong but
they're going to be comfortable making a
toast and making a joke in public you
know how much I mean your first podcast
is probably unwatchable by you right
mine is like that too so you get those
at bats out of the way early on and then
when they do have to speak and they're
speaking for their career now um having
the background where they got you know
they made the mistakes on a podcast or
on a um on a Tik Tok video where 90% of
people are young people are getting
their news you know there's I don't get
into I have a small Tik Tok following
now I mean small like what's what's the
Brian keing Professor keing yeah Brian I
I had Dr Brian keing and then I lost
access to the phone that it was
associated with God damn it I talked to
president Z in China and he he pulled
some strings but it didn't work anyway
so uh so I triy Professor keing yeah
exactly uh but I just put my YouTube
shorts on there basically so it's fun
you can find on YouTube even better but
anyway it's a whole new dimension of my
personality I wouldn't have known about
it if I didn't try I was scared the
first dozen times I did podcasting and
also you know there are perishable times
in like you might not ever be able to
get Kaku back again I don't know maybe
you know or me or what you know what I
might move to Nobel you know to
Stockholm or something all right um so
who knows and you only do things in
person right I'll fly from Stockholm you
basically get uh you know couple swings
at the bat and you don't know if you're
ever going to get that chance again so
if you're talking to
somebody um you know it's risk-taking
it's a whole other you know side of
organization public speaking um you know
communication explanation some people I
work with are not good on camera and
they want to do animations that's super
cool like for a kid to do like research
and not even a kid some I have some
adults that just volunteer they make
animations for my explainer videos on
YouTube because I do explainers and
podcasts which is probably why the
algorithm has no idea what to make of
the Bri Dr I keep doing that yeah it's
fun and I I'm going to keep doing it you
know I've tried to be divorced from the
hedonic treadmill of you know how many
Subs how many likes comments and stuff
like that um it's impossible to be
completely you know separated from it
because you know not it's and and and I
should say I don't get you know the line
share of my income from the podcast but
I make a decent living you know I could
I could subsist on it if I needed to um
you know with way better setup how
you're doing it though because you are
you have the career you have the
legitimacy there you make your money
your podcast scratches your itch of your
interest it's safer for me than it is
for you I I admit 100% but Julian
there's there's 47 other um I should
even say because some of my colleagues
do listen to all the podcasts that I go
on and and they're they're looking for
you know little nitpicks with me but but
I'll say you know there's dozens of
colleagues that aren't doing it and
there's more that aren't doing it but
even not doing it I don't even mean
start a YouTube channel I mean just go
on other people's shows you have a paper
that came out why did you publish this
paper on this type of weird Liquid
Crystal that that behaves at the certain
property when polarized light is exposed
to it okay um it's it's very Arcane very
OB but someone's going to be interested
in it some little Briana or Brian is
going to hear that and say wow like I'm
really interested I never knew how that
worked and if you're really good you'll
explain it in terms of something well
like your iPhone is a different type of
scen and you can it's totally different
than cosmology I admit cosmology aliens
Consciousness those are the biggest
topics I can think of studying which is
why I focus so much on them on my
podcast
but there are other things and a good
guest as you said you get people to come
in here that maybe aren't the most
famous you know blown up people the
hubans the you know whatever but you get
them on the show and they tell stories
and they're good storytellers and then
they get there what happened to Paul
Rosy that's right you know that's what
happened to Andy Boon yeah exactly and
and yeah I mean and and by the way
you're doing a a a kindness a Hess
you're doing the kindness for them
because who knows if that's part of
their future second Mount their career
and to not do that and not go on other
people's podcast I I've had on like the
most dry boring if you read his papers
you'd be like this guy is and he's super
cool and interesting when he talked
about the podcast about superconductors
and room temperature superconductors and
he would those first podcast he asked me
recently when am I coming on again cuz
you can bring it to life it's fun you
can bring I'm having fun you cannot beat
somebody I had Gad San on my podcast
recently he's another great guy you
should have him on um he's up in
Montreal is he the m byus guy he's the
parasitic mind that's right the
parasitic uh he's got a big YouTube
channel large Twitter following and uh
he was basically you know he's basically
the happy poet the happy warrior and I
said to him like you have all this
vitriol and like after these attacks in
in Israel you know he's Jewish he came
from Lebanon as a refugee you know how
do we maintain happiness and he's like
if you're not happy you're losing like
if you're not doing it and there's an
old quote like you can't beat the guy
who's happy like these people that come
out after Eric or whatever like Eric is
a happy guy most of the time you know I
mean the weight of the world he weighs
on his shoulders I'm sure too but he's
enjoying he just loves it it gives him
pleasure and people like that people
like Fineman people like Einstein people
like Kaku they're having fun you can't
beat people like that yes that
definitely came across and it comes
across with you like I I meet people
when when they're in here you know what
I mean it's not just what you see on
camera you get a feel for people and and
by the way I should say I I don't only
like if somebody just invites me on
their podcast I don't just go on it like
but I've started to do something and I
want to get your you know feedback and
what you think of it um so I'll get
people that'll write me Professor keing
I love your work I've seen you on Rogan
and Peterson and fredman and what have
you and and now TR lean's podcast I'm
gonna get the same and they're like I
want you on I look at their Channel and
they got 3,700 subscribers so I'll say
great I agree to come on but I'm going
to set you a stretch goal I'm going to
give you some homework I'm a professor
when you get to 10,000 subscribers I'll
come on I've had people reject me as
you've had people reject you I'm sure it
happens every all time but you give them
an achievable goal that's you know not
10 orders of magnitude you know it's not
like detecting the higs bows on on their
YouTube channel but they're going to do
something and then they come back and
I've had this now at least twice where
they come back I hit it I'm so glad you
told me to do that and guess what I had
people tell me to do that and people
that even did it to me and said I would
come on and didn't come on but that's
another story so you have to be prepared
for it but it gives you ambition goals
and it forces you to up your systems and
learn all the tricks and the trades and
to me it's all about Improvement of The
Human Condition I think science is the
clear-cut tool that will allow us to do
it the fastest and most efficiently
absolutely you you have as you mentioned
talked about some of these major topics
though on your Channel with guess and
yourself whether it be
Consciousness the beginning of
everything which we've talked about a
lot today but also you mention aliens in
there yeah that's a requirement in
podcasting [__] requirement now but
you know I have so many open-minded
thoughts on that and you want to talk
about stuff you don't know I mean my God
the whole thing is stuff you don't know
but we've seen a lot of news this year
we've seen Congressional hearings which
in many ways are unprecedented as far as
the scale of what we saw this year with
grou and stuff like that but we as a
scientist have you seen anything that
points to I'm not going to say
definitive proof but strong evidence to
show first that a we are the simple one
we are not alone in the universe and be
that some of these things that are that
are being reported the phenomena
actually are true and did happen yeah I
mean the most contentious part of my
interview with Joe Rogan was about this
topic and it was interesting because I
think there's a lot that we agree on and
then there's a lot that he will just use
kind of these tropes and and superficial
arguments which I've heard for a long
time which aren't you know truly
superficial in that they've been
attributed to luminaries and heroes in
mind like Carl Sean which is basically I
call that like the surface area argument
there's so many planets there's so many
stars there's even more than Carl Sean
ever knew about you know when he died in
the 90s and he used to say if there's
nobody out there it's an awful waste of
space well I told you I've been to
Antartica and I've been there twice and
it's not a very happening place and it's
not happening in a lot of different ways
one of which ways is that there's about
300 people there in the Antarctic uh
winter which is you know our summer in
the northern hemisphere there's about
300 people on the whole freaking
continent are there any like restaurants
there anything there are uh military
bases there and the military bases
Supply food and there's about 12
different countries that have different
military bases there are we sure it's
just a base there not a little something
below there not like you know the
descendant of Hitler hiding or some
aliens or some [__] no they have plenty
of places to go in South America turns
out yes that's unfortunately true yeah
so when you uh go there you basically
resign yourself to not seeing any other
you know people besides the 49 people
that might be in your particular
military research base where we go in
the United States owns the South Pole uh
because they're doing scientific
research there you're not allowed to
mine minerals or construct military
airfields there and it's just the
military built the the research
facilities because they're the best for
Logistics like that so when you go there
there's basically almost no now not only
are the only life forms that you see at
the South Pole human beings there's
absolutely no other forms of life
effectively in other words you won't see
birds flying overhead or Penguins
walking by the South Pole is 700 miles
away from the coast so it's incredibly
remote and Antarctica itself was only
discovered like 114 year 150 years ago
in the late 1800s people never
discovered until then I've never looked
into that now that you say that holy
[__] they never reached the South Pole
until 1911 that's less than a 100y old
you know continent that and it's just
barely been explored now if you just
said the same San argument that it's a
waste of space you would say that well
Antarctica must be a waste of space
because there's only 49 people on the
you know 200 people on the whole
continent the whole continent only has
200 people on it it's the size of like
three texases okay but it's so small
relative to the universe no no but I'm
just saying just take the there's but
there's 8 billion people on earth right
there's trillions of of microbes on
Earth trillions of trill you're more
microb than you are human but it's
[__] cold down there so what we know
what we've learned about uh life is that
life finds a way right Jeff Goblin said
life finds a way life Works life you
didn't think about what you should do
you just thought about what you could do
so channeling my Jeff Goin pretty good
so yeah yeah we we uh we guys stick
together so when
you but when you when you make that kind
of argument you're assigning what's
called a uniform prior you're basically
saying that like the probability for
life should be the same everywhere in
other words we are form of life and then
any other planet like Earth should be
basically as probable to find life there
right if I told you there's an identical
copy of Earth forget about like what
else is there if there were dinosaurs
there or not I just said there's an
identical copy of Earth and it's in some
other solar system proximus and B okay
and I said um it's identical it's the
same distance from a yellow type star um
it's in the habitable zone there could
be liquid water there there might not be
liquid water there could be ice there
could not be ice there could be Carbono
what would you say the the odds are that
life would exist
there would you say it's zero I mean you
definitely couldn't say it's zero right
B zero right would you say it's 100% no
no so somewhere between okay and that's
all you can say right zero no life you
talk about not proximate holy [__]
exactly so now you look at that and you
say well the look at the planet Mars and
I made this analogy on Joe R Mars is
right next to an earthlike planet in
fact it's very earthlike because it's
Earth Earth and Mars exchanged particles
for billions of years we've been
exchanging material I have a meteorite
that I didn't give to Joe Rogan um and
I'm not giving it to you either but it
came from Mars it didn't just come from
the the Supernova that blew up that made
this one that I gave you at Great cost
and personal risk to myself bringing it
through customs and I gotta like put
that through something your mass
spectrometer here um but uh but despite
that there's no life on Mars Mak say
well Mars is different it used to have
liquid water it used to have you know
abundant liquid water it still has
frozen water it has carbon dioxide was
that evidence for life I mean we would
if we see carbon dioxide on another
exoplanet we think it's EV potential
evidence for life it certainly doesn't
forbid it so for all these reasons
there's some probability that you should
say that if life is abundant in the
universe there should be life on the
planet literally next door to the only
planet we know for sure has life and yet
there's no evidence for life now there's
not even evidence for life that existed
in the past that in itself is not proof
that life never existed there or that
life couldn't exist there in the future
but again we can only go with what we uh
what we say right now if I put a gun to
your head and I said I'm going to take
away all the YouTube plush studio and
your play button and everything I said
I'm going to put a gun to your head what
is your factual knowledge not your
belief what is the evidence for life
outside of Earth what would you say it
is it has to be zero or one what would
you say was zero or one I don't think I
can say zero or one you wouldn't say
zero I mean is there evidence I'm I'm
saying if if if you're saying the answer
can only be yes or no is that what
you're referring to there was Z one yeah
is there definitely life outside of the
Earth or definitely no life out I
couldn't say either really there's
evidence for life outside I mean have
you ever seen evidence for life outside
of the earth cuz I haven't that's that's
what I'm saying though we only know such
a limited amount because we can we've
only even I mean we haven't even gone to
Mars yet and it's a planet right next to
here we've sent Rovers and stuff yeah no
I agree but the fact is we only have
evidence for life on Earth in other
words if I say to you that there's life
on on mars or there's life anywhere on
any particular thing it only makes the
probability you know a little bit bigger
to say that that there could be life
right you're basically making this
argument that because the universe is so
big there could be life in the universe
okay okay but what if within our solar
system let's say across our planets
there's no real life on anything else
which which is a distinct
possibility that is one solar system in
the context of a galaxy in the context
of a series of galaxies in the context
of a universe that we can't even know
the limits of and I've always thought
it's incredibly
narcissistic to assume that out of
everything this place with the 8 billion
people and you know the Lions and the
elephants and all the animals and the
fish and the water this is where the
life is and there isn't forget just life
but there isn't a brilliant life form
that exists somewhere else I find that
incredibly hard to believe also
considering the fact that creation had
to start somewhere and why would the
Creator whoever that is whether it's the
god that's in written in one of the Holy
books here or something like it or
whatever it may be why would they put
and again this is an eviden less comment
to be very clear just a meta thought
comment why would they put the only life
so many infinim layers away from where
they exist I find
that I find
that I think you're over indexing on the
pocket that says we're nothing but dust
and Ashes
how do you figure you're saying that
there we should have humility and say
that this impossible for us to be the
Pinnacle of creation well who knows
maybe you should have the other pocket
that said the whole universe was made
for you not just humans it was made for
you for you to do some Grand Mission
that's the notion of these two pockets
one is I'm nothing I have to have
humility and be humiliated sometimes and
make blunders that lose me the Nobel
Prize the other one I have to say this
is this Cosmic feast
a buffet of infinite variety that's made
just for me and for me to extract
pleasure and happiness and make other
people happy and extract pleasure for
them so again what if I said you think a
guy like kou is is making it up then who
grou yeah um I really have almost no
knowledge about him the stuff that I've
seen from uh American Alchemy from um uh
what's his name uh is it Mitchel he he
did an interview on a podcast called
American Alchemy who I'm in touch with
Jesse Michaels or Mitchells yeah he's in
La I'm supposed to see him sometime
anyway he did like oh there bodies
inside and stuff like that the more
precise that you make S like in other
words I say Julian I saw a car go by
today and it was a yellow car uh you'd
say okay well that's a you know high
probability and then if I say and
there's a there's a trump rally down the
street and and and I saw the on the back
of the car it had a bumper sticker it
said Trump
2024 wh- which do you think is more
likely to have happened
um you just don't know anything else
about me I'm just telling you there's a
trump rally and that's true and I saw a
car a yellow car or I saw a yellow car
with a trump bumper sticker on it going
towards the Trump rally which is
happening right now which one do I think
is which is more like yeah which would
be more likely to you well if we know
for a fact that the rally is happening
then yeah that's technically more likely
no the more restrictions you put on
something the less probable it becomes
not the more probable it becomes what do
you mean if I said if I the more kind of
boundaries and conditions and specific
that you put on something I'm talking
about the rally itself I know that but
that could be completely irrelevant
right it could be just a yellow car you
do admit that there's more yellow cars
in the world than yellow cars with Trump
stickers on it yes so why would you
think just because there's I gave you
some additional information that was
really to distract you it's I think
we're saying the same thing here keep
going you're saying it's more likely
that that I saw a car with a yellow car
that had a trump sticker oh you're just
saying that it had I'm saying it's I I I
think I answered your question wrong cuz
now I may understand it better but what
I was saying is between the two events
the rally happening or someone seeing a
yellow car with a trump sticker which
one's more realistic or which one's more
likely well I said well it's 100% we
know the rally happened they might have
seen something wrong if they saw a
moving car with a sticker that they
maybe didn't see well it's hard for me
to parse exactly what what we're talking
about but I'll say this the more
conditions you put on something the less
likely it becomes just like I said to
you if I say you weigh less than 1,000
kilograms it's much more likely that
that's true than you weigh 104 kg 237 gr
right okay so the more restrictions you
put on the less prob so if I put more
and more restrictions on things like the
origin of life and then how did
conscious Life Begin and what properties
are reg are are required for life to
exist if you look at all the things that
had to conspire for us to be here having
this podcast right now there's probably
you know trillions if not an infinite
number of things each one of which had
almost infinitesimal probability just
flap of a butterfly's wing oh yeah flap
just look there are 400 million uh sperm
Brethren that you and I beat out okay we
we kicked them out that's one400 million
shot right literally it's I think it's
four trillion right no it's 400 million
it's 400 million yeah I don't know about
you you seem young I don't
know only us old guys we're talking
about 400 million sperms um so we beat
it out right so just looking at that
it's it's right so any any given um
configuration of probabilities that had
to come together is almost zero but if
you start speaking in generalities the
problem comes in and this is the fallacy
that Joe and Carl San others are
succumbing to who really believe it I
actually don't think Carl Sean believed
it uh you don't think Carl s believe
there was life I don't think that he
would say well belief was important to
him it wasn't it wasn't at all he would
say evidence so he would say there's no
evidence but there's possibility for it
and so that's where this this thing
about Mars being next to Earth came in
that's why I brought it up so if you you
you can't say again this didn't prove
that life only originated on Earth the
fact that Mars doesn't have life but if
you put a whole bunch of these things
together if you said no star within 70
light years of us has any evidence for
extraterrestrial intelligence or life or
anything like that then you say well
it's only 70 light years within a a
Milky Way that's 100,000 light years
okay keep spreading out there are people
that do these calculations and they find
the following statistics and these are
people that believe or if you like want
to believe that there were and are
aliens in the universe civilizations
technological which I think there's zero
there's certainly no evidence for any of
this right I mean that there are
evidence for alien PL let's say G is
Right evidence that you've been able to
see that I have uh been able to subject
or been subjected to a scientific rigor
commensurate with the scientific method
that I practice and my colleagues
practice that's right even duw doesn't
say that he saw it he says that he knows
the people that saw it right I'm not
denigrating what he says he saw or what
he believes he's certainly more of a
hero than I am on a on a on a YouTube
channel but uh but but for him to come
out and say it a great risk Etc um but
it's not evident it's not scientific
it's not replicable it's not falsifiable
in the same sense right is he's saying
that people saw it so I can say that
some people said they saw stuff that
didn't you know I don't have his
security clearances obviously but um but
look at look at all these different uh
things that have to come together for in
order for life to exist on another
planet and for technological life to
exist and so forth and I start to think
besides the the visitations from Earth
is there any other which is disputed
right nobody nobody's saying for sure
Gru is right or or sure I have on Ryan
Graves the pilot who you know with his
colleagues witnessed certain phenomenon
yeah I think he saw DARPA weapons on
that one it could be it could be yeah
he's a very interesting guy and he's
doing good work and and it's kind of
like global warming stuff like even if
you don't believe global warming is
truly happening and it's caused by human
beings reducing carbon emissions will
have some benefits to human health and
pollution and anel right so even if
Ryan's wrong and they saw DARPA stuff
it'll make the lives of pilots and
commercial airline travel and so forth
much safer but I'm really straying far a
field let me just say this for us to
believe that there is uh visitation by
Advanced extraterrestrial Ral
intelligence requires a host of
different things to have occurred all of
which would make me incredibly excited
as a physicist because it would allow me
to Short Circuit maybe thousands of
years of remember of of evolution as a
scientist it would just be like string
theories wrong sorry move on to
something else put more money in
cosmology there'd be so much advancement
in Technologies so physicists have a
confirmation bias of a vested interest
in this being correct but look at some
of the most biggest doubters of the
extraterrestrial intelligent hypothesis
these are physicists as well even people
like AI lobe and stuff he won't say that
he believes that these are definitive
proofs of extraterrestrial intelligence
or physics beyond the standard model or
other things he will say that this is
these are things that we need to collect
more data on and that's why he's
building these telescopes at Harvard and
around the world and trying to collect
samples from the bottom of the you know
marana's trench or wherever he is and
and pepu and N Guinea to try to find you
know the the shrapnel left over because
there so few artifacts astronomy
cosmology searching for alien life is
amongst the most challenging things
there can be to study if I want to study
some nematode worm okay there's
trillions of these worms or bacteria I
can do an experiment pour some you know
I don't know vitamin C on one don't do
it for the other and one dies one you
can do experiments how do you do
experiments in the cosmos there's only
one or the universe one how do you do
experiments with like uua which crws by
at you know a good fraction of you know
uh uh uh you know 10 times faster than
any commercial spacecraft that has ever
traveled you can't it's a one-time only
thing it makes what we do so hard to do
and therefore we project onto it what we
want to see and that's the cardinal sin
of a scientist it's what got me into
trouble with the dust findings and so
forth you saw what you wanted to see or
I did but let's say you're right in in
the theory about bicep which right now
obviously can't be proven or anything
like that but let's say you are and you
figure out that due to inflation we
therefore have a Multiverse does that
then bring us onto the plane of you know
when when we Define an alien it's just
something foreign that we don't think is
from this Earth we don't necessarily
know where that comes from whether it
comes from another galaxy and figured
out how to Traverse wormholes and time
and [__] like that or whether or not it
could be some sort of future human or
some sort of future iteration that
exists from the presence that we're in
if you were able to prove that though if
BP we're able to come through and
eventually find the right measurement to
be able to find inflation and therefore
say aha we may have we may have
Multiverse ey Multiverse is there platy
would that then point to the fact that
we could have people present here right
now who are as we might know them half
biological entities whatever they might
be that are those who are future humans
who have figured out how to switch
between multiverses Andor time wow you
you layered in about 10,000 different
things now you're channeling Tom dong on
me with the future humans um so I had
him on and uh about two years ago and uh
I I'll just say most of my audience
wasn't thoroughly impressed with how he
quitted himself I actually happen to
like him I mean he impossible not to
like him um and his colleague Jim
semivan who's ex CIA agent yeah he's
surrounded by Spooks that guy thaty so
everyone's like uh they ke in because
Jim said you know we're the US
government we're not allowed to lie and
the roasting in the comment section was
was just unparalleled um I'll say that
there is a tendency to kind of project
onto um aliens a sort of sense of um the
anxieties fears desires hopes wishes of
our current civilization and this is not
new this actually dates back to the
atomic age 194 it's not a coincidence
that the first atomic bomb a detonation
on Earth by human beings was done not
far from where Roswell uh is in New
Mexico or the first this crash that
occurred 1947 or allegedly had uh had
occurred uh with alien bodies and alien
spacecraft and so forth um many of these
phenomena do occur on military
installations to this very day um many
of them are um also not only kind of
denigrated by uh people of the
scientific Community not saying I never
denigrate these people that have more
courage in their little fingers than I
do in my whole body but I will say that
the some of the tell to me to use a
poker analogy we're not far from
Atlantic
City is uh how are they treated by the
people on their colleagues and cohorts
you would think that another pilot um
wouldn't Mock You Know by putting Little
Green Men on David fr's pillow or all
the stuff that he alleges that they did
and he he's crap I'm not saying he
didn't do it he didn't witness what he
did but these people should aren't they
worried about like encountering these
phenomena if they're really seen every
day as Ryan told me they're seen every
day and people report cubes and spheres
or spheres and and that no commercial
airliners as yet and he's working to
advance the report reporting mechanisms
and stuff to destigmatize it there's a
psychological component that's
fundamentally not scientific it doesn't
mean that they're wrong after all I mean
circumstantial evidence on eyewitness
testimony it's a mixed thing sometimes
it is used in court sometimes it's not
used in court sometimes photographic
evidence can't be used in court and
we're getting into an era of deep fakes
and so forth like that so Elon Musk
saying oh with all these camera
technology shouldn't the videos have
gotten better I think that's a little
simplistic too um but what you want to
do is not pit natural allies as I've
said and I find this a lot on my channel
I get comments like this of course you
astronomers you're paid by NASA to have
this opinion about uh that aliens don't
exist even though I just told you that I
would give you know like I give your
right finger to uh to uh have true
evidence scientific replicable data from
the existence of an extraterrestrial
intelligence that would be more
significant than 10 times what I'm doing
I have to say what I'm doing as a
scientist I would feel like I wasted it
and I would immediately pivot to this
and I'm not unwilling to do that I've
changed my career you know from you know
just being a pure scientist that does
nothing else to being a podcaster to
being an author I'm comfortable with
making pivots I'll do that in a
reinvention in a second has to be
warranted and so don't make an enemy out
of scientists who spend their freaking
jobs looking at space in many different
domains from the radio to the X-ray and
everything in between from gravitational
waves and then their partners and the
theoretical Sciences don't make enemies
out of us just because we disagree with
your innate feeling which is only a
feeling which is ultimately
psychological in nature and not
scientific that aliens must exist and
maybe even that I've had an Alien
Encounter we're not even saying that
don't make enemies of us partner with us
work with us support us get more funding
for Research into this I just had um you
know I'm going to be meeting with my
friend David spurgle who's the president
of the Simons Foundation which funds my
my research in cosmology he led the NASA
study panel in uaps and people came out
oh he's just a sh he did the terrible
job and of course he's just speaking the
party line because it came out and it
didn't show that there was credible
evidence um even they didn't say that
there's no evidence for they just said
that 90% plus can be explained by
pedestrian means and and they gave
multiple examples of these phenomena
from atmospheric effects to government
to spies to drones to DARPA all these
different things you give examples some
of which are redacted and classified but
and there's 10% left over but that also
doesn't mean well like you know there's
a 10% chance Elvis is still alive you
can't fault David
spurgle you can't fault the members of
this panel which are esteemed
astronomers physicists military
personnel you're you're just fighting a
losing battle you should look for ways
that you can get access to the data and
then support them and I'm not involved
in that that's not what I do I don't do
anything related to that other than host
people like Ryan and and uh Tom dong and
I'm open to it uh but um but at a
certain point you know there's emotions
run so high with this and I think it has
to do with the fundamental almost quasi
religious belief yes that we are not
alone because it's it's terrifying
Julian if we're alone isn't it
terrifying it's scary yeah so I think
that that an and I'm sympathetic to the
people that want to believe but no
scientist should ever say I want to
believe they should say I want more data
that's the thing though people aren't
just looking for the truth they're
looking for the truth they want to be
true and that's at the core you know I
try to separate all the noise with this
whole topic and it was a lot of
different topics I do this with but on
this one in particular it's like yeah
it'd be mad interesting if there were a
bunch of beings like [__] looking at
us or living among us no less or
something like that but you know I I do
still believe that it would
be questionable to not assume that
there's life out in that viciously long
Galaxy but the evidence we could have
for it here if someone came up and
showed me good evidence tomorrow that
nothing had ever been
here I and and I determined it to be
like better than evidence I saw to the
contrary I take it you know what I mean
and that's that's just the nature of the
beast but listen I would have a million
other things that I want to talk with
you about this was we're going to have
to do that this was an awesome
conversation we didn't even get to like
Consciousness stuff we didn't get to any
AI we only just scratched the surface of
aliens right there so there is
definitely going to be a Brian King part
two but I know you got to go meet with
the other Brian Brian Green over at
Columbia but before you go where can
everyone find your show what's it called
and what's it on so uh it's called into
the impossible podcast and my YouTube
channel is called Dr Brian keing and we
cover everything from the brain to the
Big Bang everything in between from the
cosmos to the Consciousness and I am
interested in in basically anything
scientific because I want to pay back a
debt that I owe to my heroes like Carl
Sean like
like Brian Green like Stephen Hawking
that inspired me that I could become a
scientist and they inspired me not again
not through their uh scientific papers
which I couldn't comprehend until
relatively recently they inspired me
through their popular books and I
endeavored to explain it never to dumb
down people say oh you're good at
dumbing down I hate that I don't want to
dumb down I want to treat you with
respect and say I'm G to encourage you
to have that stretch goal like I say
these podcasters with 3,000 Subs get to
10,000 give me something to inspire you
give me a hook give me an in once you're
in you're going to get addicted I
promise you cuz it's the best script
ever written and we just have to be
actors that rise to the challenge to
perform this play and the grandest
spectacle of nature you got a great way
of putting things man I I would as I
said earlier I'd recommend the show
heavily it's an awesome Channel on
YouTube so everyone go check it out
Brian keing thank you for being here sir
thank you brother all right everybody
else you know what it is give it a
thought get back to me peace thank you
for watching this episode guys please
make sure you smash that subscribe
button hit that like button on the video
and if you want to check out another
episode from the podcast click right
here